[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect yo what's up everybody I
am Thomas doas Yola whatever you want to
call me I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys what's up we're
going to get straight into this episode
today guys um this is is the second
installment of hex coming and hanging
out with us apparently the first time
was the most weed you've ever smoked in
one sting in one sitting you couldn't
pass it 21 cuz everybody had their own
so I'm like all right here I go and I
remember seeing Jose over there uh who's
here with us today and I was I was like
I'm like man I don't know cuz I I've
I've never smoked weed like that and I
was just very I was very proud watching
it back I was like man I held my own
[__] you kep it together I had no
idea till you said some [__] today yeah
the most since then I've obviously
developed uh a a a a bigger affinity for
for cannabis so I've been a I'm good
good way putting it smoking a lot of
weed yeah lots of it what an elegant way
of putting it yeah I've been just
smoking a lot I've developed a greater
affinity for the
pl for the
cani um all right so for everyone out
there that missed the first one hex
optic gaming Pine Park um what in a
nutshell what is your day my day in a
nutshell is content creator first
uh creator for Creative first everything
else that came along with it it just
happened to be business something that
you have to take care of obviously
because uh you know with uh with with
opportunity comes business uh I say
fortunately and also unfortunately right
it comes with its own set of uh of
headaches having
to I don't know just when you're by
yourself and it's just like your team
it's a lot of easier to say no to stuff
and then when you have a a bigger team
you have then you have respons
possibilities and you no longer have
like the luxury of just saying no to
things that you and we do right like
99.99% of the stuff that we say uh yes
to is something that we really want to
do and then the majority of the stuff
that like the 0.1% that we say no to is
just something that would never fly with
uh with the with our audience so but
yeah I mean there there's responsibility
comes with it like I have to be in
meetings I have to look at spreadsheets
we were just talking about it adult [__]
yeah adult [__] not my thing not my jam
never been my jam you know uh I got out
of the Matrix for a reason and here I am
back what did you used to do what was it
uh you said you used to suit up every
day yeah I I my latest job was an
account analyst for AIG that's right
yeah Mor uh not mortgage uh uh insurance
and then before that the mortgage
industry yeah but optic gaming uh
greatest Esports organization that's
ever lived I know my man rain has been
here a bunch of times his His Face Clan
uh the original face clam was always
obviously like OG OG OG so um yeah my my
dayto day is uh I'm just a creative dude
I I love uh anything that has to do with
uh Innovation and pushing the space
forward uh I love YouTube YouTube and
and uh online New Media like that's my
that's my jam I wake up just [__]
enjoying it uh when I met you guys and I
started doing research in cannabis and I
found you guys I was just like yes it's
happening [__] everywhere like the
shift is happening where people who
normally wouldn't have the opportunity
to to extract themselves from The Matrix
and not just make a living right but
make a [__]
really good living is uh is the dream
right because paying paying your bills
to to do what you love priority number
one everybody should should seek that
out the cherries on top that's just
cherries on top you know so yeah I put
up a post yesterday saying you can live
your dream life and not have to change
who you are yeah that's what's different
about our generation that we really have
the opportunity for we don't got to go
kiss ass in some office that you could
give some [__] about at all that isn't
for your own personal thing that you own
we have a much greater opportunity to do
that we just have to realize and and
realize what we want what we're good at
and what serves other people dude
especially with the internet man like um
the internet has is the great equalizer
right it's it's period uh the fact that
you can have your own show without Fox
without Showtime oh is that is that is
that you guys do something with Showtime
uh no we we are no longer Associated
okay yeah we're out in it's talk I was I
was gonna say [__] Showtime I'm kidding
I they have they had uh what two good
shows but you know you don't you you're
not accountable to anybody you you put
what you want to put out and people will
gather around it right like the reason
why you guys have been as successful as
you are is because the the real reality
of things is that not everybody that you
watch on camera is real yes it isn't
until somebody I just saw you for
everybody that doesn't know how this
thing works he set up every single one
of these cameras pointing them to the
right people press record on all of them
came set down press record on that like
this is a real person that people can
associate to right they they relate to
him cuz he's a real person when you get
you know the the Jimmy fallons and all
I'm saying I don't watch them so I don't
know if they're good or not I don't
[__] know uh you know there's there's
a hundred people that are doing all he
does is show up and does his thing right
like you're yeah you guys are very much
like Hands-On in everything that you do
the same way that I am with with uh with
optic and luckily I've been around
people that have sort of learned how to
how to do the things the way that I like
them um and you know I don't have to
look at every single piece of contents
anymore and and review everything but
every sales pitch every design that we
put out everything like gets these
[__] eyes on them before they go out
into the into the thing I promised
myself when I got optic back that it was
never going to be I was never going to
take my my hands off the wheel again but
I kind of want to
again that's such a valuable lesson
that's what I said when we moved back in
here like never again like you don't the
goal we thought the goal was to get it
up big enough to go you know
lab in thise that's not
theal your own
te smoke it up Che what are you
smoking what Str is it oh he just did
the we don't know I don't know B park it
uh it could be oh [__] yeah so you know
one of the things that we learned on uh
very early on and I mean obviously like
mistakes mistakes uh that that people do
when they start into a into a new
industry is first thing that I did is I
I didn't follow my my instincts in doing
the things that I've always done in in a
Content first approach to everything
that we do uh but you know now now that
we don't have uh our you know weed that
we grow uh and we essentially just
curate content uh obviously with with
the help of oo who's been you know my my
dude for over five years now longer 10
well working with me for like five but
I've
know absolutely yeah yeah yeah the the
beat conductor
uh like Mad Lib um yeah it's all about
it's it's all about curating content and
sharing sharing life with people with a
common denominator which happens to be
this beautiful beautiful magical plant
that I've been in love with since 1997
17 years old just graduated high
school first time I drank first time I
smoked [__] the smoke part like was
immediately my I was like I remember we
were in the back of my my my dude's Fort
Temple black one tinted window
red seats red red upholstery I remember
everything beautiful mind like Russell
Crow uh but I remember looking at myself
in the mirror on his rearview mirror and
I'm I'm like oh my God I'm not talking
but I can hear myself
[__] [__] love this [__] and we
and you know what's [__] up we smoked
out of out of a a roll a Holy Roller
it's what they call Ste roll yeah
Steamroller thank you yeah of uh inside
of a the the carton and then you put the
bowl in the middle and I was like I'm
yeah I'll [__] hit that [__]
graduated straight edged dude and oh you
you were done you just gr just 1997
graduated and the the story has it that
I stayed an extra year but [__] whoever
says that I'm kiding that that happened
I didn't get my I didn't graduate
graduate until 1998 because my high
school failed me because I didn't know
how to swim stop it yeah I you failed
gym class back then gym was [__]
important not like it is now there's no
shop class there's no [__] gym class
there's no there's there's no is there
art class anymore it'd be a [__]
shame if it wasn't
get the [__] out of kids need to be told
what the [__] to do they need guidance
you kidding me you couldn't swim so they
failed
you no obviously because you can see the
physique right super athlete I was a
basketball football soccer your name
throw him in some water he throw in the
water and I was like oh how'd you get
here I like well I was born in a [__]
Apostle Texas prick you know what I'm
saying see I got to be honest that's the
first thing I would have told my homie
about you didn't swim how did you get
here with your family it's the first
thing I would have said yeah yeah yeah
grow up in Mexican town bro take shots
so you grew on the river I know that Rio
Grande it's like well it's chocolate
water you can't swim in chocolate water
you know what I'm
saying so you can't I'm sorry you can't
did you learn oh yeah okay you can swim
now yeah yeah yeah me me me and Michael
Phelps have a have a match soon okay
what they make you do go back and just
[__] do the water graduate it's the
most asinine thing I had to take night
school to get credits night swim classes
no it's just gym it was gym class but
because I didn't pass my swimming El
it was like it was like in quarters like
picture a year in quarters and the first
one's like the Mile right like your your
cardio and your Fitness and then it's
Sports and then it's swimming uh water
polo and all that [__] it's cool like
come on man and it's it's and it's the
the '90s right so everybody was [__]
naked in the locker room and I was just
say yo I'm get out of here I didn't come
to America for this are you kidding me
I've never heard of that in my life you
get in fail for gym yeah Wheeling
Illinois shout out my my my hometown
love it used to be it used to be more
more important though I will say that no
it's no longer like
nobody no gym class no no gym class can
you no no shop class the shop class is
the the the most it teaches [__] I
almost cut my hands off in shop class
right here yeah in metal shop teaches
you to be careful yeah I was high as
[__] I never go to school high you went
to I went to school first period how old
were you you started smoking 13 13 how
how'd you get weed uh this guy named Sam
Mars Mindy me and Joe started selling
weed for him well we bought weed from
him and started selling it in school in
shop class well shop class where I hit
all my [__] and then on Sundays cuz all
the wood in the metal stays outside so
I'd hide it in there but I remember one
time you know the sheet metal Cutters
you press the weight and it goes cut
sheet metal was talking to my homie no
and I was like yeah man blah the teacher
come high and I was about to press and I
went and it was right here no I would
chopped off all my fingers dude just
imagine how much tougher it would have
been for you to smoke a joint roll it
bro I would just had little scars little
scars like Frankenstein you think you
would have well you think you would have
had fingers still yes I would have got
him back somehow I would have learned
how how what year was this i w it was
2004 nah dude there's no 3D
hands they didn't install H hands on you
and
[__] I just have old
kids one of my best friends uh from high
school his name is
Frankie he uh he was he was a serviceman
and then he got into construction and
then he lost the he lost the tip of his
finger Doe just like just construction
yeah no just a I think it was like a
wedge that just like you know metal
metal and SK don't get along sometimes
yeah I've seen some
[__] yeah it's it's uh you know with
technology now like man it's you can get
anything replaced you know it won't be
the same sure but you know what matters
is what's up here and you know whether
or not you're a good person it's crazy
is we went from like metal arms from
like kids need to learn kids don't got
Direction get some metal arms this is
why it's my favorite podcast I come in I
I I mean obviously when when uh when we
used to come like on a day like the
monthly basis and I used to do pine
content with highly productive and all
that stuff like I was smoking like
frequently on camera uh but since then
because of the way life has happened for
me I haven't had that much time out here
uh and luckily again like I said joseo
and then obviously the boys uh Tim and U
oh [__] dude what the [__]
happened
be anyway um they've been on the Ford
and just like elevating like the weight
they have they're just [__] insane
you guys just adding on Goblin to the
team yeah man it's uh it when when
relationships happen especially business
relationships happen out of out of uh
out of friendship and and and people
that you like to hang out with is just
an easier thing you can tell by by your
guys' relationship right like it's it's
more than just uh it's more than just a
job this a lifestyle that you get paid
for right that you get paid to do so you
got to you got to thank the internet for
that you got to thank obviously the your
supporters for that because you know
it's reciprocal right you entertain them
while they're going on their way to work
or while they're making food or whatever
it is whatever it is that they consume
they get something out of it too right
I'm not saying that it's just like a
one-sided thing but um it's the most
blessful thing that anybody Blissful
thing that anybody could have could have
ever given Humanity I think
agree so we're going to be seeing the
Gob cast coming out of the Pine Park
Studio soon he tell me about that
yeah J will give you a better rundown of
that but you know we're just we're just
doing what we've been doing for over 15
years at optic right just uh just
expanding on the shows that we already
have and just giving them more um I
think one of the one of the best things
that we did at optic was was not putting
ourselves in the box and saying it's
like we're Gamers period right I was
never a gamer right I I started playing
games when I was [__] 20 2026 in 2006
my girl my wife now my girl didn't want
me to get a a Xbox 360 cuz it was going
to sit and collect dust
you know what I'm saying so you know
little little decisions that you make
will reshape and shape like your life
forever cuz I would have listen to her
other day realize that any other day I
would have said we're at Sam's Club and
I'm like oh I played Call of Duty uh at
GameStop I'm like think I'm going to get
this game and the reason I didn't like
Call of Duty at GameStop was because it
was it was inverted so if you press down
your character looked up and I didn't
[__] with it hate that so but I'm like
I'm going to give it a shot cuz I like
it she's like you're not going to
[__] play that [__] like you you play
poker and you fish that's all you do you
paint trains at night what an active ass
dud got so many hobbies and interests
dude it's the best thing the internet
has allowed me to be able to turn my
jobbies into Hobbies man like it's the
best thing [__] ever that's sick
[__] love the internet thank I wish I
had a hobby damn I can't draw or I don't
like fishion what what do you what do
you do outside of it's nonstop people
ask me all the time it's safe to say
weed is your hobby I would say I mean
but what am I doing ask this guy what
his hobby is trying to sleep in between
all the [__] that's my [__] like what do
I do I don't know we you're mcing you're
DJing you're [__] editing that's
that's my life dude I love that if you
live a creative life no matter how much
you get paid you have a purposeful life
you're utilizing what something up there
put in your DNA and in your brain to be
good at or have a passion for and if
you're not actively seeking that on a
daily basis you're you're not doing
you're not only disgracing yourself in
your and your abilities and and and
creativity but something else something
more powerful they gave you that I'm not
I'm not uh I grew up a Catholic but I
don't I'm not a practiceing but I do
believe in in in a in a higher vibration
you just know yeah that's just like an
intuitive thing that it's like yeah it's
my potential it's my purpose out here I
have to push that's what I'm here for
that doesn't make me feel as bad because
sometimes like what do you want to do
like I got some [__] I could work on I
have nothing I I don't have things I
like to go do because I don't have the
time to go find out if I like them I
really dude I like I don't like stuff
what do I do I have no [__] idea yeah me
and my wife are like uh you want to go
to the movies and get highest [__] like
yeah cuz I have [__] to do in like 4
hours oh my god let's get it done like
what what sort of [__] just work [__]
constant everything just okay we get
this video done over the clo and I got
the reup now we got another started
another [__] business never drops
it's just it's just like there's
something every day of the week and like
well that's fine yeah no well I mean I
think I think for you you you found the
thing that just captures your mind and
and allows you to [__] operate at a
high level sleep doesn't matter personal
relationships matter in the back of your
head but in in in in in your life's
purpose is is not minuscule as
complimentary to right my my wife is has
been like my biggest [__] investor my
biggest supporter like gangster as [__]
you know what I'm saying because she
[__] doesn't she pushes me like
graffiti go [__] paint you know like
go I just have so many [__] things
that I like to do because of my ADHD I
mean you [__] have it you have
mastered it or something cuz to only do
thing like speaks against everything I I
I know about people with ADH CU When
you're so busy with like optic business
it be very easy for your wife to be like
spray paint the [__] you talking about
where you going family time the fact
that she's like supportive and all that
is awesome and I do have family time
right especially now like I've uh not in
the last three weeks but i' I made it a
point to take her and my daughter like
everywhere I go uh but you know for the
most part my life has been all about the
hustle right like it's uh I heard a a uh
a saying somewhere that said if if you
don't come from a rich family a rich
family must come from you like that and
I to that [__] to hard you know what I'm
saying uh and that's what I've been
working on and then and then spreading
that and making that a contagious thing
amongst your your your group of of uh of
friends is like the number one thing
mind like I I cannot I I helped this
dude but not at all all also right
because I I need him to [__] swim and
I know that he can do it then and I'm
just like I give him a little guidance
and I I I just let him [__] run
cuz when when you learn something about
life you have to [__] spread it
otherwise we're we're a server to The
Matrix mysterious how wrap that up I
like doing this show there's so many
different brains get to come and sit
down yeah and I [__] dude I'm saying
I I soak up little pieces of game from
so many different [__] and then
like right now like if you go from Rich
family I love that so much yeah and and
and Rich obviously doesn't just mean
mean money yeah it doesn't mean money
you know happiness is the is the is the
biggest uh Financial tool you can have
it's checking a lot of different boxes
that lead to like fulfillment I feel
like but having money is one of them
that lets you check a lot of those boxes
obviously yeah I
uh I look at I look at life now and the
way that it was in the past and I'm just
like man these are the like the artistic
effort that went into everything that we
did as humans like in the early early
days versus the Contemporary modernism
of [__] cold surfaces and sharp lines
and houses and all this [__] like
everything has like nothing like look at
this it's just Sleek it's sleek and it's
minimalistic and it's perfect and it's
beautiful right but man when I look at
stuff like this and like handcrafted
just like etched things I'm like man
like effort wouldn't look how
symmetrical that thing and it came from
my brain not a [__] machine right
some Mexican dude somewhere [__]
snapped on this thing that's exact what
happened I see that you put it perf some
Mexican doing hard on this [__] that's
exactly what the [__] happened with that
thing too thing is I like that sharp
lines contempor I but then again I'm
like wow look at that Colonial House
from
189 character wow you go to Pasadena you
see all those old ass houses that are
haunted I would love to live there but I
trying to get [__] haunted for my
rest of my life I [__] hate scary
things me do I don't watch scary movies
Thrillers I'm okay with but Spirits nope
done cuz that shit's real and I don't
want it coming back to the theater with
me I'm good dude open up my brain to
some [__] I'm good thank you I'm
good I'm good cuz you can't hit them you
know what I'm saying thank you that's
what I always they don't communicate
with you a zombie you you know you can
[__] the head off you're dead you're
done a ghost how you going to hit him
that's why I don't [__] with the the
ocean I can't talk to a shark like bro
we'd be homies they're basically ghosts
they they disappear they're Petty
they're [__] pett they're all you
know are they Petty they are B you
they're scaring you they're leaving and
coming back they're calling their
friends and
[__]
um yeah Spirit they they they have to be
Petty right because uh orca whales are
Petty they'll remember maybe not Petty
but bench Beneful because um no they're
dicks yeah they they'll remember right
like they started flipping uh boats oh
you're good just scrape it you're fine
it's all good man this table is a
[__] mess insane after that adhc I'm
surprised that you guys don't have the
people that that come here like [__]
sign the [__] boom boom boom and then
you [__] take it apart you [__]
Frame It season 2023 we've been doing it
on posters and stuff oh [__] we' been
doing a little stuff and trying to
figure out how do we do that we're going
to tape chicha's like smoked joint to
the poster to the poster and lack how
many did he smoke let me get one of
those butts so I got to frame it oh
they're gone 3.5 Canon
yeah he he was smoking it man what a
legend cool guy yeah what a legend was
awesome yeah yeah like uh even when else
in Mexico I I I I would know about him
right so you know that he transcended
yeah was on the border so we got a lot
of the signal from the United States and
[__] like that but
cool what's one thing you've noticed
Texas Mexicans California Mexicans
what's the differences cuz I've only met
a few homies from Texas my family's from
Texas I'm just not yeah yeah so I
noticed
the big trucks really matter over there
big trucks yeah I have one oh do you we
call them lalona oh there's a name for C
oh my
god there like [__] 10,000 Mexicans
laughing in the [__] there are there
are probably more right and if one of
them's eating uh Ramen laughing cuz it's
too hot they do look bro that's my whole
life growing up I never [__] with the
ramen like that cup ofp like the the
murrian or what no the cup of soups
where you where you're supposed to put
hot water says do not microwave and
everybody microwaves yeah how the [__]
else are you going to do it you put hot
water in it and you close the top how
you going to heat up the water with the
oven no no with a stove but nobody wants
to do that you might as well make
noodles it's a lot of extra steps it's a
lot of extra steps man yeah you know
speaking of uh of like hobbies that turn
into jobbies the one of my latest uh
projects is is called idiots yeah
telling me about it yeah idiots is a uh
it's a graffiti show based on food right
so I was like man I got to get back into
painting and and then I started thinking
man you know like my audience has has
seen me draw my you know the the whole
time they've known me uh and I'm like
well let's make a graffiti show but what
and then I'm like man a food and travel
show is like the the the best thing
everybody [__] can relate to that so
that's what we've been doing for the
past uh like I just got off a 10 day
stint in Chicago just [__] visiting
restaurants after restaurants after
[__] five restaurants at a day
sometimes um you eating going hard every
time hard
oh no that's why you said I lay down and
get palpitations bro I I was I I was
telling them before the camera turned on
is that when I would get home when I get
home when I would get to my hotel room
good pillows uh right I got to my hotel
room I I would lay down and then my
heart would just be
like like when I would lay down and I'm
like man this hypertension to the to to
the forest luckily a friend of mine from
a friend of mine that I know since high
school became a doctor and uh he uh he
was like yo what's up he's like just
check your pulse I'm okay so I'm going
to check my pulse and it's going to give
me a
number okay it could it could say 911 or
15 over 40 or what I'm not going to
understand so I'm like I'm calling you
for a reason yeah give me a [__]
phone diagnosis right now listen to this
right
I'm I bet you can help you though huh
what was the solution my wife I uh she's
like I'm going to send you some [__]
uh what some enzymes and [__] some pills
to take natural [__] digestive you're
just eating too much basically is what
we're getting at I I was eating too much
yeah dude think about it all right you
wake up at 9:00 you're out the door by
10:00 you hit the first uh restaurant
for breakfast right so whatever was so
you get your breakfast and then you try
their Specialties [__] uh uh French
Toast French toast right you [__] sit
there and you eat it's [__] delicious
they got [__] strawberries and very
specific Maple very specific uh
sourdough bread that they make in house
and they crust it the right way etc etc
etc do you go with like the house
toppings like what's popular yeah yeah
you don't you don't change it sausage
they just like sausages in there was
that a was that a 40-Year-Old Virgin yes
thought so I heard it went virgin to me
I love movies but uh so from there you
you you had you know that you're going
to have lunch somewhere else right but
it's already [__] 11:30 so you might
as well just go straight there so you go
and have lunch right after that I'm
burping and I have not eaten not even he
just thinking about it just thinking
about body digestion brother there's
like no more [__] keep that [__]
out um so you go you go have lunch and
then you go to this Ramen place I'm not
going to tell you the name because you
gotta wait to see it but the the the
people there know why you're there and
more often than that these these
restaurants are Standalone restaurants
with a with a chef that has a lot to say
and a an establishment that he has to
pay for and people and people's Ames
that he or she has to take care of so
she's got to be at the [__] toughest
so you take any form of AD advertisement
that you want and then when when you see
that season one went [__] as well as
it did they're like yeah yeah so they
[__] they're overly generous overly
like yo try this try this try this and
I'm just like to Buffet now man no so
dude so you eat so I'm give just give
you one day right so you you get the
ramen and then from there you're like
all right we have like a 5H hour break
until until uh until dinner like yeah
you want to go get drinks at around four
it's like yeah where we going to go here
all right so on the way they're like oh
dude there was a [__] fire ass Taco
spot right around here and they're like
we got to go let's go so you [__]
pull over you don't eat the full four
tacos that traditionally you
would so you eat two you take a bite of
the third one just because you don't
want to make it seem like you don't like
it because you do you just have and then
from there you go to dinner and the
dinner as you know it's like the the
fancy [__] James Beard Ward uh one
Michelin star like you know fun [__] and
they have seven course omasa like
[__] you know displays and you it's
it's a picture a [__] person having a
concert like they have their opener
right their intro and then they have
like their sets they they have like a
full set seven set song and then they
[__] the last one is the [__]
Banger uhhuh which is dessert usually oh
no the enor is a dessert anyway so after
that bro like you have food you haven't
[__] that out you have food you have
food it's just sitting there it's
stressed me out listen it did it
stressed me out a little bit 10 days in
a row oh God 10 days in a row what do
you mean 10 days in a row you have to
film 50 restaurants six six episodes for
the season in 10 days it'd be easier if
my my uh my good friend and co-host of
the show uh Juan Chef Juan yep Kim AKA
Revis CMW if he lived in Texas it would
be way easier because then then we could
just like cover [__] oh you only have
a little bit of time we only have a
little bit of time because because you
know I still have a job right like I'm
not I'm not just this character in this
[__] show um and uh and yeah so that
was that's day one and then you you get
you get to your hotel room it's like
it's time to go to bed because you got
to get up at a certain time and I
usually go to bed like 9:30 anyway yeah
and it's like 10:30 11:30 and you got to
drink I don't [__] drink ever but
here I am [__] drinking fancy little
cocktail drinks M mad fancy did you feel
sophisticated yeah dude you put your you
put your elbow and I I told you guys
this last time right like the Victoria
liims the way you smoke them you put the
elbow on your rib and then it's like to
look like yeah so same thing with
[__] martini glasses right you do the
same thing the swirl and you sip it so
blunts after blunts after blunts right
and Chicago like here is legal so you're
just [__] oh yeah any anytime
anywhere and I don't traditionally smoke
tobacco leaf anything right it's pure
pure paper or sometimes the bong um so
you have nicotine plus
sodium plus [__] gluttony you know
what I'm saying plus uh just a belly
full of just [__] goodness so when
you lay down your body your the blood's
not rushing the same way cuz it's got
nowhere to go the heart squished your
lungs are like yo what the [__] stomach
is this what your doctor said no that's
what my
imaginations yeah I uh I imagined it
like those uh Pixar cartoons uh where
they all talk to each other yeah the Oru
away from me the organs are just like in
there like what the [__] epidermis make
some room epidermis I was thinking about
that uh Simpsons one the other day your
epidermis is showing Bart falls and
breaks his leg and can't swim for the
summer just thinking about that one last
night yo you explain things I love the
way that you took me through the day I
feel [__] disgusting full yes I do
cuz I was imagining every step 10 days
in a row so I know I'm fat but I don't
even eat a lot that made me stressed out
maybe next time make it like 14 I was I
was
206 I'm 6 foot handsome 206 6ot handsome
206 4 43 years
old when I came back I was 210 do you
want to know why because every morning
my [__] big ass got up and I walked
three miles the Michigan Avenue okay I
was to say this I typically I'm not it's
if it's not Sports I'm not exercising
I'm not lifting weights I need to score
a bucket against somebody I need to
[__] throw a ball far as [__] that's
my thing lifting weights you clearly
it's not my thing so walking [__]
helped and I wouldn't have done it if I
didn't feel like absolute [__] every
single one and it wasn't how many cities
is this so far uh Seven Cities damn so
far but season 1 was uh season one was
Texas so we did El Paso where I was born
the best one El Paso San Antonio San
Antonio Houston Houston Austin Austin
Dallas and in Dallas we went to my mom's
house for breakfast and you know showed
that um and then we went to Fort Worth
to Goldies which is the best barbecue
I've ever had in my life period and the
storian they're they're all good but
this one was [__] special special oh
my God great so we did those and then
Chicago uh by itself but you cover
[__] so much dude you had
Mediterranean we had uh uh obviously
Japanese we had we had it all dude
that's cool though oh my God so what's
the painting oh and then we we paint
graffiti and all in between all that and
that's you're full as [__] yeah well
that's the only that's the additional
movement that's the additional movement
I can only imagine the oh the other day
I went to mastros we flew a fan in right
like yo look get high [__] for the day
they won a contest then we went to that
that restaurant what was a contest uh we
we sell not a contest we sell there's
one subscription box we sell gota yeah
yeah and they just got the golden ticket
they got the golden ticket for the DOA
shop and they won like we've had 10
winners and this month that month was
like you fly out for the day yeah right
we've offered that twice and I won't get
too into it some people are not very
nice and don't give a [__] so we got one
guy I'm like yo FR for the day he goes
are you yes [__] yeah and then we looked
up his name like this [__] does
YouTube I've seen this kid's face
already 420 Julian love that yeah I'm
like you already do YouTube and you won
so he came out and then dab dab for
[__] dab non-stop from Chicago yeah
dab for dab never stopped he was ready
he took six blinkers in a row and no
cough off our pen six and I had him stop
because I felt worried professional wow
yeah but the thing is we went to a
restaurant and you know there's like
John my my business partner is one of
those guys like let me try um all of
these and then we'll all pick them apart
yeah I don't even mean [__] so I'm like
yeah let me get the [__] spaghetti
yeah and I'm sitting there eating 12
pieces of BRS I'm like [__] you guys are
eating a lot of [__] I'm waiting for my
spaghetti so I felt like that like
afterward and then we go get some weed
and he's like we should go to dinner go
what like by the time we get there so I
went there went to MOS or whatever they
got the whole [__] thing here I am
just eating sides but by the end of that
[__] when I got home that's how I felt
yeah it's the worst feeling of all time
yeah dude I love food I hated food I
love food I hated food bro I got I got
home well I fasted from uh I got home
Thursday morning I fasted all the way
until uh Friday night just water oh to
get ready or for after the fact after
the fact I just didn't want to see food
oh my God yesterday we went to a
restaurant called uh fun F fun funky
yeah fun Fu n k it's by the same people
that had uh girl in the goat have you
been to girl in the goat have you been
to girl in the goat dudes you guys have
to go it's so good we're vegetarian and
vegan so we're annoying oh yeah it's
full yeah we we're [__] boring but
you want to eat some plants you say that
but my dad just became vegan like uh two
years ago had hypertension had a a a
diabetes had had diabetes now it's gone
gone yeah and he's in the best shape
he's ever been in yeah wow he looks my
age sick just as handsome no kid uh but
yeah he's uh he's clean eats clean eats
everything I look at him my pop I don't
know how you do look at my plate look at
your [__] plate like your shit's got
avocados
and yeah but my shit's got bacon and
sausage bomber I never liked bacon even
when I ate me I never was never a bacon
guy no now this fool didn't eat me since
he was a little kid I found out a year
and a half into me and him hanging out
and we order food again I'm like what do
you mean no chicken he's like I don't
eat meat go what you either I haven't
eaten meat for like seven years this
[__] I had known since he was a
kid egg like eggs none none no Animal
product no you he [__] with that yeah
okay okay okay yeah no fish I eat cheese
and stuff but no fish loveish no you I
love cheese love see I used to love the
[__] out of it yeah and then when I
stopped I tried to eat it one time or I
accidentally took a bite or some [__] no
not for me when you accidentally eat
something
you realize the restaurant forgot to
leave it out it'll make you want to
like you want to kill people over these
animal
rights I'm not the animal rights guys
vegans are [__] annoying 97% of them
are annoying I just don't want to eat it
I'm not going to [__] preach I went
to a steak steak house two days ago with
my homies I'll see salad and bread and
be bored uhhuh yeah but no dude there's
a lot of fun [__] you just have to
really care and uh find it but like in
Texas I hear there's a bunch of dope
[__] my family is from El Paso I've
never been I have a lot of family from
Bor yeah like when you were saying like
I've never met them but I know I have a
lot of family out El Paso may not have
the same effect on you as it did on me
because you know some of the stuff that
I was eating was uh very very meat meaty
but there's this restaurant called elmi
in El Paso Texas James Beard award uh
husband and wife uh uh restaurant their
son works there also uh bro the best
Mexican food I've ever had you know
outside of my mom's house and my mom's
house is very TR this this was a a an
art show right like this
dude fire and it's the majority told
where I was going is that up until a
certain point I call it the halfway
point had all been vegan and I hadn't
noticed I hadn't noticed that I hadn't
eaten any meat aside from the aach
chilas which had a little bit of shrimp
but aside from that everything that I
was like eating all the cadas all the
Brussels sprouts that were [__] get
the [__] out of here uh were [__] you
know there's no meat in any of that I
guess what is it vegans and what's the
other one vegetarian yeah it's more
vegetarian not vegan because pescetarian
the one that eat no no it was cadilla so
they had cheese in ites yeah so I I I
didn't even notice and I was like man
that's that says a lot
because you know for for somebody like
me who eats meat on everything and
considers it not a full meal if there's
no protein in it or meat uh I was like
surprised I'm like man I can't believe
I'm enjoying myself this much yeah it is
possible no I feel you Dude especially
in the Mexican culture that [__] is not
look at my grandma's no what's worse a
vegetarian or a pothead oh a pothead
okay for some reason it's like yo do
bricks hit your wife is fine yeah don't
you be smoking a joint out here my whole
family's cool with it bro my grandpa
beat the dog shot my grandma every's
like yeah no it's he's a man like bro
it's just [__] it's ' 80s '90s it's
not cool never been cool but man never
cool there's there's so many this is
very weird we as a as as a society have
to grow you know and it takes a while
for information to get out there you
know you grow up ignorant you don't know
what the [__] you don't know that you're
ignorant you don't know what you don't
know it's a definition yeah amen that's
why did you sanitized I dude I'm high as
[__] and I was just like I don't know
why but anyway you did okay I was yeah I
did I don't know I saw it and I'm like
we have hand s there yeah that's from us
in between in between joints I F I felt
a little bit Dusty little [__] um
next chapter yeah yeah yeah no it's like
I I I I make it a rule to to tell
somebody they're stupid when they're
being stupid just because I don't think
that there's that level of
accountability in this day and age you
know grown up like I said in the '90s 43
years old some of the stuff that people
get allowed to say without any
retribution and then they think that
they that that you because you are
popular that you don't have a that you
can't defend yourself right and I'm like
that's not the way the world words
matter and you should be nice or you
shouldn't be anything at all you don't
just mind your [__] business if you
don't like something right injustices
and and and that stuff obviously always
stand up for the for the for the smaller
person always but some some of the [__]
that I've seen on the Internet it's like
BR where no no one has ever told them I
think people don't get hit yeah doesn't
everybody's inside violence is sometimes
the answer I am very passive but
sometimes that 5%
it's like yo just knock that man asleep
and all the problems stop right now at
this bar hit him but it's like don't hit
him at the same time cuz you start
thinking like you hit him and he falls
the wrong way and then something else is
happening not even that just I feel bad
I you ever [__] fight you been in
fights but you've been in fights right
you ever been in a fight where like
toward the end they're like oh it's like
I feel like a bully now you're like
you're you never felt like that no oh I
do I've got the first fight I ever
gotten where I was beating the [__] out
of the kid as I'm hitting him he's
crying
with I feel and then I socked him anyway
but I was like oh and I felt amazing
that pic me up my neck that kid deserved
it [__] him what what's his name Brandon
oh my God he sounds like a prick he was
a little dick he was two years older
than me you know what Brandon we know
that you changed your waist and that's
why you continue to watch him now I all
I got so you know what if you've changed
your waist then I take back what I said
maybe maybe that's that last name just
in case he's like a man of God now yeah
like yo I'm a man of God but I'm [__]
watching you guys dud what happened is
there was this slow girl named Sarah she
was she was very slow she was extremely
slow she had Down syndrome she was very
nice but she was like 6'3 she was a
giant person MH and I saw this fo punk
in her and he was pushing her against
the wall and I was and he was already
picking on I was like oh this is it yeah
this is the time and I beat the dog [__]
and then I got to to go camping the
weekend and while I was suspended was
like Dean tired I got no trouble Mr Dean
Johnson I'm not saying I'm [__]
Spider-Man but oh you beat somebody's
ass oh you I saved someone you know what
I'm saying what happened what's the
situation you got you got chug a
frutopia there's nothing wrong with
standing up for people you should stand
up for people every time don't put
yourself in
danger Common Sense tough yeah the fact
that I have to say hey unless it's
unless she's got [__] weapons you
know at that point you know then I'll go
try to like yo come on man come on hit
him I'm not going to stop don't hit hit
this I've broken up a fight with weed
have you yeah love that I could see that
I gave some P some nugs they all stopped
tell tell me about it I was in Denver
and it was 24 yeah and you know once you
turn 25 you don't get that tax on rental
cars and once you're 25 you don't have
to have like a second piece of
information to rent a car I didn't know
that so I'm stuck at thank you for
putting me on game yeah so I was stuck
at the Denver Airport with me and Rosie
and just going to the Cannabis Cup like
are you [__] kidding me I don't have
a rental car this is terrible I'm stuck
my first time out there and there's like
six dudes all just looking at each other
three like all you could tell they were
together but all of them were just like
looking at each other in like one word
and they're going to go nuts so then one
fo's like how are you going to forget
your [__] wallet and then they all
just started screaming at each other
they were stuck at the rental spot too
no but they all had New York a they were
all [__] aing I was like oh you guys are
from New York oh all right and they were
all yelling at each other and then one
of them started getting in his face and
what the [__] and they were yelling like
they were friends yeah but I was like oh
[__] they are going to [__] fight
damn all right I'm about to watch a
fight at least while I wait here and uh
I was like [__] that something's got to
happen they're going to be stuck out
here and I I brought two Zips of
cookies and I undid my bag and I got
like three or four nugs and I walked
over as their argu I was like yo
you guys need to smoke this [__]
everything's going to be okay and they
went no [__] way all of erupted with
laughter started laugh because they
they're uh they were going to The
Dispensary they had no [__] weed they
just came float from New York they were
all pissed their one homie didn't bring
his [__] uh he love Denver yo no no
not even that all of them erupted super
stoked I got a I got a taxi into town
all this [__] walking in my hall my
hotel Boom come across them they stand
on my [__] floor at the can CU
they're on my floor in the Hotel 6 years
later I'm at the Rainbow Room no I'm
with Benny from Buffalo and I'm sitting
there different Benny different Benny
and this dude's looking at
me I'm like all right was like 12 dudes
at the rainbow room like oh nice to meet
you guys BL he's like you look familiar
I'm like I got to be honest you look
like somebody I met in Denver I have a
CRA you know like you look like some
dude from Denver goes the Enterprise in
Denver you gave me cookies right I go
shut the [__] he's like I knew that was
you he's like we were going to kill and
I I asked the for a whole rundown yeah
the one homie that planned the trip
forgot to [__] book The
Rental like how you going to [__]
forget your [__] and he just didn't like
confirm the [__] so they were stuck and
nobody else had like a they're from New
York nobody has a license from New York
nobody [__] drives so like all of it
made sense like wow weed sto a fight
though it's pretty cool I [__] yeah
the best so why' you beat up Dean no you
guys did no you did I beat up Dean you
said Dean something that's why I beat
you up no you're Dean you know cuz you
saved the the the girl God oh my God
there's no Deans you didn't you guys you
guys don't have Deans when did you
graduate what year graduate 2007 2007 27
20 so 10 years after me yeah we had we
had principles and then we had Deans two
deans Deans yeah one his name was
[__] Mr Lane and the other one I
don't [__] remember her name but uh
we had a cop and a principal we had we
had a cop too it's Wheeling Illinois the
dean in my school the dean in my high
school's name was you had a Dean too
yeah his name was Mike Hunt stop stop it
swear to God he got he never got the end
of it come on he never got the he the
end of that [__] stop psycho he reminded
me of the uh Warden and sha shank uh oh
with the glasses M the piece of [__] who
got what he popped himself oh yeah he
killed himself he popped himself yo top
three favorite movies go
snatch my number one good [__] oh look I
I'm going to say the three you want to
talk genres then obviously I can get
more precise okay ready favorite three
movies that um more drama Thrillers like
snatch I guess you would say more action
the gentlemen and rock and roller the
gentleman uh those are all guy Richie
movies yeah I say you went hard with the
guy Richie [__] right now makes the best
gangster movies ever rock and roll never
seen it it's great dude Tom Hardy Idris
Ela [__] Gerard Butler Edis elba's a
oh great great actor oh yeah so wait
wait wait all right snatch great movie
that's basically who my mom was married
to Brad Pitt and snatch is beating the
[__] everybody but in jail Mickey gotcha
yeah [__] man call me Mickey yo that's a
great movie did you ever see lock
talking super Smoking Barrels first one
that I watched 1997 nice shout out to my
boy Danny biki he's the one that [__]
put me on yeah yeah Uncle John put me on
to that one I was like wait this is a
comedy over yeah he he was he actually
put us on like he's he's like the
ultimate super D like picture the model
dad the perfect dad that's what he is
now but back in the day he was [__]
gangster as [__] polish kid had [__]
black Taekwondo black belts and trophies
oh [__] the size of the [__] ceiling
and [__] but he put me on to like uh uh
put me on to guy Richie with lock and
Two Smoking Barrels and also anime um oh
wow yeah Akira G in the sh that's the
only one I've ever seen that's the
[__] show I've always trying to
reference oh okay guys there's only
anime I've seen what's his name Aira
Aira Aira yeah my homies like AA they
always scream I go what and then I watch
it was amazing bro it's like [__]
sick I saw that and he's like yo this is
how this is what you see when you're
when you're tripping on acid right cuz
he had they were like uh our group is
divided at the time was divided into in
in athletes and [__] partyers and
they were on the paryer side we were on
the athlete side so they they already
been Shuman [__] doing acid and then
there's that part in Akira where his
brain tumor like makes makes him see the
little bear come up and it starts
[__] melting so [__] good great
art anyway so I don't know where how we
got there but yeah oh black Stock and
Two Smoking Barrel he put you on the
anime yeah all right so you're a movie
guy let's [__] go okay here we go so
um lock talk and Two Smoking Barrels
blew my mind I was like uh nine or 10
when I watched that yeah blew my mind
snatch is great haven't seen Rock and
roller and you said the gentleman is
that with Tom Hardy no or the dude from
of Anarchy right yeah with uh Charlie
hunam from another
movie that I
love Green Street Hooligans oh yeah yeah
what an ending yeah you got that's
something you you [__] with that that's
a good movie with the greatest football
club ever West Ham United you know what
I thought the other day America took a a
sport named at football when they knew
football already existed stupid sh up
and then made pop soccer like not cool
for 40 years and now soccer's becoming
like yo this is what soccer is yeah has
a lot of camaraderie and now America's
waking up yeah it's true we straight up
stole the [__] name yeah we did what
and it's okay to say we yeah we're
Americans man we did we really did we
couldn't come up with our own [__] for
football you just took it and added a
different spelling that's pretty wild
that's copyright infringement I've ever
seen when you barely use your foot in
football really I mean it's the kickoff
it's the they rename I mean we use
inches man instead of the metric system
hey man we're right that's right we're
right all right I'm G take that I want
to be the most American person
ever yeah I'm just I know I thought you
had your own sh we got we got one more
who my God one more little one little
Chopper hey what's up everybody just
taking a moment to talk about one of our
brand new sponsors and this is water boy
we have all woke up at 6:00 a.m. hung
over having to go to work wishing that
we didn't drink if I just described your
morning water boy got you covered water
boy this powder is scientifically
formulated to cut your hangover time in
half so if I just got you hooked already
go ahead and go to Waterboy
docomo as usual and get 15% off your
entire order that being said let me get
more into it we've all seen the
hydration powders but none of the other
ones on the market are like water boy
this has zero sugar and three times the
electrolytes is liquid IV non GMO
gluten-free dairy free vegan friendly
and above all no sugar at all this is
not just hydration I'm talking about
when I get get hung over I'm clutching
the toilet I am spinning this is
scientifically formulated to help cut
nausea and fatigue down so if any of
that hooked you right now again go to
water boy.com and use our code at
checkout dope as usual for 15% off so
what I'm saying for everyone on that
Sunday morning reach for the water boy
okay it's going to help scientifically
formulated to help once again thank you
to our brand new sponsor water booy back
to the episode I got a question speaking
of the hell weed first time you smoke
weed after you graduated high school
were you already a graph artist at that
point Point yeah how did oued change you
as an artist it changed everything
really yeah bro it's like for me it was
uh it was it it allowed me to focus on
one [__] thing and the only thing
that ever allowed me to focus for an
extended period of time was graffiti
because I sucked at it I wasn't I'm not
a natural born artist right like I can't
draw your face the way that you know
some of my friends can you know what I'm
saying they I can't draw this these
glasses and the [__] way the light
hits it to make it to let the Shine Go
and all that [__] it's not it's not the
that's not the kind of artist I am so I
had had to practice hard to learn how to
you know make the letters bigger and
then that so that is the only thing weed
weed was always the only thing that
allowed me to [__] super focus on
something oh he's saying you have ADHD
Focus I don't think it's for me it's
Focus just like am I bored yet yeah mhm
I'll be in business meeting and within 3
minutes just yeah I'm tired when was I
tired you don't smoke in
meetings I mean I'm usually smoking
nonstop yeah so I figured like one of
one of the first uh like when when we
first came into this I we had a meeting
with uh with Skelly from
710 got you he was [__] smoking in
the zoom I you know came can I say that
I can say that right it's coolest
[__] right so I was like I'm
like man this is this this is where
we're at in society now it's normal
right they say someone's just smoking a
joint you can't operate when you're
drunk as [__] unless you're like a no I
a certain type of we Clos coffee for me
yeah especially cam driver for me oh you
talking about the strain cam driver so
Sunday driver and cam dog yeah haven't
had that [__] in 8 months 9 months maybe
a year my favorite right I mean it's not
our proprietary thing it's been around
for you guys grow it gotta we did yeah
yeah and it was the best man it I
remember that it it just uh it allowed
last night we smoked a hash hole and I
had the same high I had the same high
where it's like it's not Misty right and
I'm not talking about the smoke I'm just
talking about like your your the the
clarity of your understanding my the
fluidity of my sentences was just like
perfect with weed you know I get a
little stuttery sometimes as my brain
catches up or my mouth catches up to
what my brain's thinking but with this
thing I was just
like I heard that you heard that bro
that's how I felt for 10
days but
wait I got okay so you disagree weed
makes you feel oh man I think I'm SM too
much weed F it's the only way for me
like I I smoke and then now I'm dialed
in and I'm doing what I'm doing yeah
it's a superpower oh I'm do that's
what's wrong with me I'm doing seven
things at once like when we're
texting I also am doing the comments of
something or we're on FaceTime doing the
comments of something else and we're
doing something else and I'm on the
computer and I'm doing this and Rosie's
texting me this and oh yeah I got to
buzz this fo in I got to do this wait
when do we take pictures oh [__] in 30
minutes [__] that's my brain my brain's
like this
n and then you try to [__] pick up
the pieces and I go oh [__] oh I'll do
2% of this and 2% of this
I hate my brain M blocks all that out it
just just do this yeah it's pretty good
yeah I do like a like all right I'm done
with this edit all right I'm going get
get a curette going smoke this ball real
quick I'm going to reset come back here
and do these thumbnails reset sounds
smart that done never done that do what
a reset a reset yeah on little the
projects throughout the day listen the
second you get bored with something you
still have to be productive otherwise
you feel anxious well me I do so I'm
immediately onto like the the the next
thing the majority of my day is
obviously optic and all I think about is
like how do I make this
cooler not not that's what I'm thinking
not more competitive right because
that's going to happen uh with the
people that but it's like how do you how
do you create more cohesiveness amongst
this team so that they're like it's more
than just like you know a a business
relationship and it's more like a
camaraderie right because that's you
know you got to be gang mentality right
like you you have to believe in
something um or patriotism you know
whichever one you want to go for but
uh you're depends depends on how you
grew up right um but but yeah like I'm
I'm just thinking of like cool shows
also that we can bring to the table and
like that's what I love to spend my time
on like on a daily basis that's all I
think about even when I'm drawing I'm
still thinking about like like ideas for
shows that we can bring that would that
I think my audience or a our audience
would be interested in and not just for
optic for like each individual person
I'm like oh man Maniac should do this
and [__] Seth should be doing this
and like not just our uh our cohesive as
optic but also like their individual
like show ideas for them that they're
not doing or they're not taking
advantage of
but I DHD yeah well I I I I think I do
too for
sure thinking about thinking of one
thing right now while you were talking
about that is insane I can't just sit
there and draw mhm holy [__] you can sit
there and clean right you can sit there
and roll a joint you can sit there while
I'm roll a joint I'm making sure my
phone's good I'm checking texting 10
people back same while I'm roll a joint
same same about Flow State I feel like
especially when you're out there with
the spray when you're on like a big big
project you draw you do that kind of
[__] yeah see I need to start maybe I
should start drawing yeah dude focus on
something start with letters man it's a
creative thing or it's just I mean it's
also a skill to stop other things that's
the skill I'm lacking when you start
tracking your time that's what I learned
when I started tracking my time like you
have to block and stop other things to
focus on the one thing and get to get to
the next thing on the list you know for
me it's all about doing it the same way
every time making the list the routine
of it is the only way to get through
everything yeah so you have a great you
have a good routine down no no okay damn
it it it it may seem as though I'm very
disciplined in the decisions that I make
but in the way that I operate to get
there to to get to it like that I I just
let the autopilot go and while I'm
taking these business meetings whether
it has to be with a brand initiative
sponsorships events or whatever the [__]
it is that we're doing I'll be doing
I'll be doing something else whether
it's cleaning and arranging like or
putting everything back in order my in
my home office or in my garage or at the
hex quarters like I'm not just doing one
thing at once like I I I I I am able to
balance doing what I would love to do
which is allow my brain to put [__] back
in order so I don't have to be thinking
about it while at the same time cas
ually talking about something that I'm
passionate about that's work for for uh
for many I'm just like doing two things
at once one offsets the other and it
allows me to one be good at my job that
requires me to you know the corporate
side that allows me to do but also the
creative that just allows me to live I I
I am a miserable [__] person when I
don't see my wife or I don't draw like
that I'm just the worst person you could
catch me I'm just going to be Snappy I'm
just like not Ed Zen [__] hex yeah
yeah [__] X
no I saw that you just you said for the
first time in 20 years I just painted
this giant outdoor mural how was that
that good I mean again it's uh one it's
like my My First Love ever my first love
outside of family like you know personal
love my first personal love that I that
I just couldn't think couldn't stop
thinking about it right when I
discovered graffiti for me it was like
kids discovering a Pokemon in a in an
unpacking so every time I saw a new
graffiti writer that was [__] good
that I like liked I was just like oh my
God this and I would imagine what they
would be like I'm you know 13 years old
I would imagine what they would be like
not knowing that they're [__] 2 years
older than me I would just like mystify
them into this this massive thing um but
yeah it's uh it it's once I became an
adult and you know graffiti is illegal
uh and painting permission walls isn't
really that fun because of at the time
right now I I I enjoy him more because
I'm 43 and whatever but I had to I had
to focus on my career you know at the
time was banking um and then mortgage
then whatever so I I couldn't risk
getting arrested getting a felony or so
I quit graffiti for the longest time
it's like that the only thing I've ever
loved more than anything else right um
cuz allowed me to be creative even
though I didn't have the tools so I had
to work hard for it so like I earned it
uh but yeah that's uh that's uh that's
20 years after that I my boy was in town
we painted a wall it was the first time
same same letters as before like nothing
really changed but the techniques the
cans are different everything's
different it felt felt good to get back
out there and then right there and then
I'm like okay I got to figure out a way
to be able to do this while still being
productive and helping optic in some way
and that's where we came up with the
show
idiots oh wow through like what by like
filming that painting the idea came
about well no I mean the idea of having
a food show has always been there uh but
there was no no reason for me to
go out and paint right like it's just it
takes hours you know this 4 hours start
of the day you made it part of your
business yeah well for now yeah so I
almost quit mid-season last season cuz I
couldn't sleep and I'm like I'm going to
call it because of the food it's only
three [__] episodes on this season
[__] y'all you know what I'm saying like
yall understand you guys are going hard
as [__] if you're about to quit yeah I
was and I'm like I'm like I was don't
understand man they don't understand
[__] that and uh and I was like all
right cool woke up the next day cooler
heads
prevailed my wife sent me those vitamins
and I started to have better movement
not that I've ever had trouble with the
movement you know what I'm saying I'm
disciplined like that but that's where
the discipline comes out yeah but uh but
it did uh it did it did help
tremendously tremendously like I was
just able to operate for the next 5 days
cuz it was literally like on that Monday
and we still had all the way to uh
Wednesday too film it sounds like he's
getting ready for the Super Bowl yeah I
got to eat all this [__] no dude it is
my Knuckles and [__] for real I got
anxiety over that but I feel you but it
was so good bro oh my Chicago man I had
a pizza puff for the first time and like
oh what's that do you know what a pizza
puff is do you know what a pizza puff is
a pizza puff picture a Kone okay right
but instead of being folded into an
empanada shape which is like the little
that instead of that it's folded within
itself to make a square okay so you have
the you have your your uh your dough and
then you put uh you know the super
ground up pepperoni and sausage and uh
cumin and the [__] cheese and then
you fold it Fold It fold it and then you
deep fry that [__] and you pull
that [__] out it's just right out of the
[__] fry yeah dude you [__] lick
that
[__] damn that sounds [__] bomb if
you ate meat yeah hey man some fried up
mushrooms sounds bomb in [__] yeah I
know cauliflower hell yeah yeah I don't
you know eating eating fancy food has
has opened my eyes to the possibility
that you can't have good food without
meat you know yeah I've seen some fancy
ass Foods in our travels that we're
doing the meet and greets yeah I'm I got
to be honest bro like if I never left my
small ass town I would have never
experienced any of these things I never
I ate burritos pizza and hamburgers
until I was 22 years old gr cheese and
peanut butter and jelly that's all I've
ever known I mean basic yeah like nobody
cook my grandma Cooks when she hot dogs
potatoes and eggs in the morning my
grandma goes hard my my Grandma Grace
yeah she calls them weenies I call them
hot dogs I don't like saying Grandma
give me some weenies I don't like it she
always say no you want some weenies I'll
take a hot dog grandma Yeah buy those
big packs from Costco oh my God that's
all I grew up on the cheaper the better
o that [__] was you you eat the ham that
was in water n dude remember those
packages of ham floating in water nasty
n balone for me I used to [__] with
balone with the red strips yeah you
[__] you you you floss with them so
you can keep all that we were just
talking about them the other day with
Ralph it's like man you should make
[__] shirts out of that [__] well I
don't know about that I'm kidding can
you imagine the smell of that thing like
a day
one it's like what's all disgusting we
ruined his childhood you made your
people made baloney
up he's all pissed on it what's your
favorite movie of all time uh TR Melle
Truman Show's pretty good it's a good
one love it I wouldn't I wasn't
expecting
it I thought you gonna say it was always
for well well Forest C used to be my
favorite forever and then Truman Show
just overtook it I just think it's I
haven't watched The Truman Show since I
watched it the first time you got to
watch and I watch movies over and over
and over and over again when I'm drawing
I'll put on Rome the the the full season
from HBO have you seen that no do you
watch shows yes slightly never heard R
do you watch shows no R is one of HBO's
greatest top five shows HBO let me right
maybe I'm capping hold
on so Game of Thrones never seen
it I like people with accents like this
succession success you never seen it
wait is that about his dad's the
president he's about to take over or
like a president of a company yeah [__]
that [__] was boring I got about two
episodes in and went so he's going to
take over his dad's thing and his dad's
going to come back and I give it to him
and I watch him so he's not dead [__]
this show I wrote it basically good is
it the main actor dude just didn't catch
I feel like it should have been joh no
there's no main actor the son the man's
not the main actor well I mean it's
about him in the first two episodes It's
the mosten are with him no it's about
the family and it gets set because uh
Kendall is trying to get what's
rightfully his according to his that's
his name righty maybe maybe that's what
it was yeah you should you should give
it a shot the name the name Kendall [__]
I'm
not I got to hear somebody get called
Kendall for [__] the whole season
[__] that so Su session I just tried to
watch it the other day and I I I just
what's your favorite show of all time
the office the office is good I love it
it's just I've only watch it once it's
that or the Seinfeld but there's more
characters in the office so I have to go
the office I never watched Seinfeld I
did watch uh Larry David Kirby
enthusiasm Kirby enthusiasm I I did
watch I I watched I'm I'm lying I did
watch some uh Seinfeld we watched this I
was like four five yeah so like right
when it was coming out was when I was
watching it and my grandma and grandpa
were laughing like oh that must be funny
and I watched it and then they watched
Frasier I was like this is you sat down
you're like what is the deal
exactly exactly Jerry me too that's how
I feel I can understand it as a kid but
Frasier I'm like why is he got an accent
but his dad's from America I just didn't
get him like why is the dog the funniest
part of the show of what Frasier sucked
what's Frasier you never seen
yeah yeah so Frasier is not a character
in Jerry Seinfeld no sorry remember the
show Frasier yes okay I'm just making
sure sorry that show sucked my [__] said
what my [__] my [__] yeah had your brain
got stuck yes yeah no no no sorry
Seinfeld's is [__] but Frasier sucks
yeah was that a spin-off or what why'd
you bring up Frasier cuz it came on
right after oh I'm always thinking about
[__] as a kid like oh sfi's funny but
Fraser's not and people battle me on
that [__] and you were out there
painting trains you don't watch Seinfeld
painting TR yeah it's different man see
when it all goes by the age too cuz like
when I was 19 like I was not watching
UFC anymore I was selling drugs and [__]
but I used to watch the [__] out of UFC
as a kid yeah I was actively there every
sat or every time it dropped I'm I'm
watching it so there's a lot of things
that you fell off on so I just think it
comes with age like Seinfeld is probably
not for you MH but it's like I just so
stupid and funny I what did I watch but
I watch marry with children great show
uh fresh bre of valir yeah um so yeah no
TV TV there back back then was good I
like I like it was good I even watched
that Full House Full House is cool yeah
when I was a kid once I got a little
older I'm like oh this is like some you
haven't watched the second uh I tried
did you yeah but I saw that [__] I was
like had no no I'm like I'm good even if
they even if they brought back uh if
they brought Thundercats back I would
watch that show that's different those
aren't humans that's fun you can do
anything you want with cartoons true
that's why South Park's still on not
everyone was ever offended still [__]
he's still in fourth grade yeah he's
still is he 13 no he's nine nine or 10
he's 10 D what a [__] great idea dude
you know I was think you watch soupart
uh yes but not religiously like have you
seen them like which one the
seasons if you if you have a specific
one in mind I can tell you yes or no
okay I got you I got you I've seen when
when you poop backwards yes oh out of
his mouth that was disgusting so good
there's a lot of uh cultural moments
coming from South Park yeah and I don't
know if it's going to end and I think
like you know when your favorite
cartoons like how would you end D think
about the show think about the props
that that show needs because Tastefully
being a little bit racist in the way
that they they do that and nobody
[__] canel them because they
understand that it's [__] levity it's
funny yeah it's funny do you have they
been tried have they tried to cancel
them I'm sure they have they went oh no
who cares they they made a cartoon about
them and yeah and probably made fun of
the person trying to sue him they
they're they're the ultimate I think
uh cultural [__] trolls I guess you
would call it yeah you know but
basetball did you see that movie great
movie bro I didn't know their dicks were
that big shut the [__] up did you were
you expecting them to be that
big when I was a kid I was like yo what
why what is happen somebody who's never
watched it they're like what the me I
love this reference yeah there's a scene
where they pull their pants down and
they're in the locker room and their
dicks go from here to the [__] cars
right a water hose and what I did right
there I'm like can you believe SFI
believed that they were actually that
big oh oh oh if he didn't explain I
would I wouldn't can you believe their
dick with that big uh what a good movie
though yeah there's a lot of good
silly what's your favorite movie it's
like a five-way tie between uh Pulp
Fiction Training Day Dumb and Dumber and
juice juice yeah like it's about it yeah
yeah yeah but for kabes what's your
favorite three kabes h that's hard cuz
every time you watch you go this is my
favorite I I I I can tell you I can tell
you I can tell you he's thought this
out let me think it let me think it cuz
I I care a lot about yes my opinion on
things man which one all right it's hard
it because your humor changes some of
the cuz I went back and I went back and
watched that wedding crash
that's good anymore couldn't couldn't
couldn't sit through it really I used to
I used to love the Rapport that [__]
Vince Von and Owen Wilson used to have
now it's a little I'm just like oh
man yeah it sucked I was no it didn't
suck it didn't suck it was but I
remember crying dying last in the
theater room when he was getting jerked
off under the table if you guys haven't
seen it you guys won't see it coming cuz
he
didn't he and did you know that Visine
no longer gives you diarrhea because of
that movie yeah why would they let it
happen in the first place I add the
diarrhea yeah no it's uh I think I think
it wasn't because of the movie that they
removed it but the movie did bring
attention to the fact that because
you're dropping the thing and it goes
down your nasal tract into your stomach
and then that chemical reacts a certain
way that you get yeah water pumps into
your intestines trying to wash it out g
science science
so not Wedding Crashers not Wedding
Crashers but I feel you am Vince vaugh
plays the same character every movie
yeah that dude dude I love that dude I
used to love that um you seen clay
pigeons no Vince vau oh yes yes I have
is is that where he goes to jail no
that's where he's the serial killer yes
yes yes he's like 20 have you seen the
one where he goes to jail yeah at the
end when I paused it and it was a it was
a man mannequin yeah maybe it was a man
that wasn't a person and I paused like
they used a mannequin wait so you don't
think that what I can't believe they
didn't use the real person for that
scene that movie wait did you like the
movie no okay I'll say it was one of the
worst movies I sat all the way through
you know what the worst movie of all
time is though Mexican blow Mexican blow
yeah that's a movie never heard of it
it's the worst movie ever called driven
driven why does that sound familiar
Sylvester
Stallone F1
F1 driver it's an F1 driver BR what do
yourself a favor and torture yourself
for an hour it's not it's not even an
hour and 10 it's like like 93 minutes so
I I I make that up maybe but it is the
worst [__] acted movie I've ever seen
in my life and you can't help but to to
to to to not be able to look away from
the car crash that's happening right in
front of you you cannot help yourself
but to just not take your eyes off of
what you're
witnessing I didn't know we were passing
until you dude my bad well me and Marty
always share cuz I don't know the guests
sometimes they're like y'all so my own
they're very I mean you roll your own I
do that too you know what I'm saying I
do that too that's funny I do do that
too like okay so driven yeah the worst
movie ever worst movie ever yeah it's
just bad acting and it's corny man in
jail cell 13 I think is what that called
right the Vince V movie man in jail sell
something something like that yeah
something bad they're in a basement or
like in a d basement dungeon with no
lighting supposed to be a prison all
right so I like I like your pics I like
Pulp Fiction uh I think it's obviously
Quinton is the [__] man yeah
uh so funniest movie for me Dumb and
Dumber I is the first time that I I
really [__] cried laughing in the
theaters back in
1994 cousin my cousin Pepito and [__] um
and our boy Sergio that's what I watched
it with anyway that one I think um
Brothers uh what Step Brothers is it's
one of the most genius genius put
together movie just like everything
about it the silliness of it and like
they they you they made me believe that
that existed you know what I'm saying
those two characters existed right um
yeah just those two I don't I don't want
to I'll sit here and talk for her they
capture being a 5-year-old very well cuz
our nephew was saying some [__] I'm like
and I said like John C Ry really nailed
it talking about Rosie two days ago yeah
they really did a good that's that's
faor
well Step Brothers is up there yeah I
watched on the plane coming back from
the plane the other day I watch also
watch Princess Bride for the first time
in a long time yeah oh my God Sol what a
good movie man yeah um my favorite
comedies
man I don't know that's that's hard yeah
Austin Powers is up there that's Watch
Gold Member 2 on the way back from this
flight I watch gold member nacho lib the
Bahamas oh nacho
lib uh watch nacho lib princess Bri Nach
Li so good what a movie bro great never
got cancelled he never got can one of
the most yeah for what cancel for what
because people always say well he played
Mexican but bro he played Mexican well
dude you know what give him a pass if I
may speak for all Mexicans we claim we
claim Black Jack any day of the week
Black Jack Jack Black any day of the
week yo what a good quen black you know
what I'm saying oh you know it's a real
story I was reading about it on the
flight no 23 year year career the guy
had as a [__] L he's a Luchador and
he runs the orphanage and he has him in
his like his outfit it's the same [__]
he's wearing a mask no it's it it says
his name and everything I just I just
liked it even more I don't think you can
have a favorite I mean I don't know
favorite comedy's too hard for me man
yeah man same you put them into action
live action [__] Maverick cuz I just
watched the uh Hangover part one the new
one yeah Top Gun
yeah yeah I watch don't tell me you like
you didn't like don't tell me you didn't
like it hey don't I know where that door
is now you can't
leave really I'm going to say this
you're quoting good phis there I get it
but I was saying that I was no I was
quoting Bronx taale yeah Bronx tail
sorry
yeah kith just did a collab with h with
that movie sorry kith did yeah really
the movie yeah yeah kith is a lot of
sick collaps good one too yeah this
one's the the second iteration of that
New York uh [__] they just did it oh
that's a cool idea I like that so good
yeah Maverick Maverick so the only thing
reason I didn't like it is because it
wasn't
good you son of I could have told you
every scene that was going to happen
like and at the end he's going to be
pulling up and and that's I just it
wasn't dude I I didn't really care about
Top Gun as a kid you know what I'm
saying NE I just didn't really care so
like like coming back like oh my God
what's the best action movie then best
action movies I think or Terminator oh
that's pretty good all right I know it's
a little hard to get away from
Terminator better than Matrix Matrix to
me Matrix is different it's not even
really an acttion movie it's everything
in one okay it's the Earth it's life
that movie is
crazy terid is just good old fashioned
fun mhm it's just a big buff robot I
that has an accent it's funny that you
guys both brought up Matrix and
Terminator because you know the theat
lady right the same [__] it's oh like
copied oh it's like
a connected movie or whatever okay
that's like I didn't know that the
skynet's real that's a fact it's called
Tesla he needs to knock it off listen
all all all I all I need to know all I
need to say about AI is that I support
whatever decisions they're going to make
in the future I am on your side if you
were a human I would offer you a joint
and uh we'll see you in the future what
a nice
answer second second uh second tier I
love that youill me second you know what
I'm
saying throwing it out there we think a
lot of life we do we do that often but
but we don't care it's okay every time
we say something about the government
but I'm not going to do anything about
it I don't
care yeah is scary uh Will Sasso we're
talking about for M scary good though
you get what I'm saying scary good yeah
yeah they can go it's the smoke it's the
smoke my eyes he has a podcast well from
M TV called dudy I thought you were
going to say AI has podcast he has a
podcast Marty
go the podcast is basically curated by
an AI
intelligence that brings up random
topics throughout the shows and does
stuff outside of the show about the show
and you know how gathers and like did
you see you saw black mirr uh yeah the
uh Jun or Jen Joan is awful
yep it it like tracks his their like
call history and the things they do on
their phone it will record them at
random times wait how how how how they
connect their phone to the AI so at any
time it can pick up a conversation he's
having in the bathroom and bring it up
on the show hey when you were taking a
[__] yesterday here's the picture of you
it comes out while you were looking the
internet it comes out as a like a
co-host it's the co-host oh my God
imagine and like say yo uh
um she was a little bit too smiley on
the last conversation she had with that
[__]
mechanic you know starts throwing [__]
out there now you're [__] it could
bring up some [__] it got them sued by
Tom Brady yes it made a AI like one hour
stand like dudes you [__] out a one hour
comedy bit and AI generated Tom Brady
voice of just doing one hour stand up
yeah as but Tom Brady and as Tom Brady's
jokes and studied 1,000 hours of Tom
Brady interview listen although I think
that it's very Advanced and could
probably do it if it wanted
to right now because it hasn't tried I
don't think that it could be more
creative than uh than people no people
but then you look at the images that
they create you're just like
[__] I know as an artist it
hurts it's like yeah it's pretty sick
some of the [__] but that's how good
that thing is you know what I'm saying
it's like what can it do you know what
I'm saying yeah it's becoming like a
normal tool now like in Photoshop an
illustrator AI is built in now is like
color swatches are you know like you can
type in and tell it what to generate so
editors are now doing that too right
like you you put in your podcast and
then you know I mean it's not there yet
it's not there yet like they'll you they
they'll have a frame over here and
you're talking like they'll Fu up yeah
slightly yeah yeah but Mar yeah no
Marty's the AI
editor it'll be a useful tool in the
future
it's 100% I'm happy for it so let's I
want to ask a question Pine Park you
guys since we've last talked talked are
now in Oklahoma and uh Michigan and
Michigan you guys just did the meet and
greet day right we did well they did I
missed my flight well I didn't miss my
flight it was like uh [__] show at DFW
day and I have I have I have TSA now but
I had I have clear and I have a first so
I should be [__] there was no first
and there was no clear and it everybody
was [__] mad screaming sweating
breathing and I'm I took a picture and I
[__] ran out of it ah I [__] R
kicked the door open I'm like sent a
picture of Jose yo don't [__] fire me
don't [__] fire me but I'm I'm not
going to be able to make it you know uh
but yeah it's uh it's cool you know it's
it's uh it's the same thing that we do
with with optic right the same thing
that googan does same thing that good
good golf does uh the same thing that
every influencer in the world does right
like um what's called an influ creatives
creators you know whatever but you know
people people through shows and Brands
and and and affinity and relationship
building that that you have because no
matter you you know more than anybody
but no no matter how you look at it like
this is a real relationship that happens
and it is a real one because you feel it
and you experience it where you're in
the world uh so you know with with that
having the ability to go meet some of
the fans that watch the show in person
people that have never met me go meet me
in person and that's the opportunity
like that's what brought us together
weed like you know it's awesome and if
if they just show CU people do show up
to just say hello right they smoke or
whatever uh but unfortunately I wasn't
able to make it um but michig was a
[__] sick ass turnout 3,500 people
wow uh on the first day like 2500 on the
second day from from the the video you
saw in the video like right the the L
sell weed right the line side yeah yeah
yeah so awesome partnered with uh
uh we partner with a dogghouse um in my
head I was think bro my brain was saying
I saw Green in in like I saw their logo
mhm I saw their logo but it said Green
in my brain when I was trying to recall
it right now and then I saw the Oklahoma
one you guys did too yeah man shout out
my boy
Eddie um it was it was good again it's
it's opportunities to meet the people
you've never met friends you've never
met right that's that's what meetups
that's what popups uh it's it's it's
something that you create and
opportunity for people to meet each
other and luckily unlike movie stars
unlike [__] all you know stars and
all all these people like uh you know
you have the opp opportunity to be more
personal because of the industry that
you're in you know 100% so so that's to
see you guys doing that and Community
like that yeah dud you know but you know
I I give all credit to to all to all
three of them
um you know I I I when we first started
this thing it was like it was supposed
to be one thing but still in the end it
was going to end up to be like what it
is just like a Content machine that just
curates and and has experiences and
relationships um and erican obviously
like one of the one of the best not just
in in weed either just like you like you
I think you you you you him um have
transcended just the Cannabis space
because you're you're more than that and
people know you for more than that you
know what I'm saying so you know whether
it's business or or just as a YouTuber
right like this there's you're a
YouTuber before you are anything else
because that's what got you to to where
you're at right or that's the way that I
see it personally um you're a creative a
creator that wanted to share so erican
like you like you know Transcendent
people that are that are doing you know
that the sky's the limit for so the fact
that we get to experience that firsthand
is like it's a magical thing Agreed 100%
And I've seen it right I've seen it in N
shat I've seen in scump I've seen in you
know all my other teammates I've seen it
in in the outdoor space like you know
when people are special and if you don't
mind me giving you your flowers and and
my boy Eric like special [__] people
you know you guys elevated that and and
through that you brought a lot a lot of
people me included with with my team
because we elevated each other like it
it you know we raise each other up and
that's that's what you guys do that's
what Eric's doing with Tim and you know
it's like [__] great great cast Josef
obviously the beat conductor in the back
H yeah I appreciate it's really cool to
be a part of yeah and and it's just
starting which is kind of weird you guys
been doing said 15 years I'm a year 10
200 I think it just started 2009 is when
it was like full [__] pedal to the
metal but we've making I was I've been
making videos since 2006 my first video
that I uploaded to YouTube was me
painting and Armen uh which is a Reaper
which means refrigerat car uh flat panel
white oh got train and uh I made it
private I was just shown it to friends
cuz I didn't know what YouTube was or
what it was and then so 2006 when I when
I started making videos what's up guys
taking a moment to talk about one of our
brand new sponsors and this is borash
and like I said last time I'm super
stoked about these products because
[__] actually the facility that they
get manufactured my homie runs that spot
one of my close friends and he's been
telling me about this brand for months
and then I finally saw them and tried
them and now they're a sponsor this one
right here is GMO and inside this box it
explains fully what live resin is so
when you get these at the store you can
actually see every single thing about it
so these right here are their pods these
are the little pods right here the pens
so if you're on Instagram go ahead and
follow bash let them know the dope as
usual podcast sent you they have Edibles
and these are board has Edibles so in
these there's grape strawberry orange
lemon and blue raspberry 100 mg for the
entire bag 10 Mig a piece so thank you
so much for supporting the brands that
support us thank you to board
hash it tastes [__] awesome what's up
guys just taking a break to talk about
one of our longtime sponsors and this is
manscaped before we even get started let
me give you this information to take
advantage of this deal right now right
now if you go to manscape.com Yola or
you co Yola checkout you're going to get
20% off of everything and anything you
buy plus free shipping and they have the
perfect package 4.0 luxury and grooming
kit the perfect package is a play on
Dick joke manscape is right on point but
also they are the leading company on
Earth for maale grooming and mail
grooming kits 8 million customers and 16
million balls cannot be wrong when it
comes to manscaped lawnmower 4.0 you
already know it's skin safe uh Wireless
chargeable has a light on it it's
waterproof that comes in the the perfect
package 4.0 along with crop preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant crop revor
ball toner disposable shaving match or
the magic mat plus two free gifts is the
travel bag and the boxers this all comes
in the perfect package 4.0 go ahead and
go to manscape.com right now for/ Yola
or like I said use code Yola at checkout
get anything or everything I just said
for 20% off and free shipping thank you
guys so much for supporting the
companies that support us back to this
ridiculous episode what's the like uh
current state of Esports would you say
like we had fa kind of a double P
question we had FaZe Rain on and he was
like kind of saying like oh the people
at Call of Duty like he didn't really
have a lot of positive things to say
about evolution of the game I understand
so you know if the current state of
Esports if you were talking to a kid on
like the best thing to get into right
now where's the most potential like
still everything everything is good the
business of it is what's bad what
happened to Esports is that it didn't
have a chance to develop itself into
what it was going to become for sure
it's still going to become that it's not
going anywhere it's a dark period but
it's a dark period about across like all
Industries right yes think about the
Cannabis industry right think about the
the the open markets think
about the housing market think about
everything right um it's happening
across everything uh I don't know how to
explain it but I saw van neistat do you
guys watch him Casey n brother Kate
that's the guy you talk about the V vog
yeah so his brother van is [__] is a
genius also um but he he put He put me
onto this thing where you know life
happens in 80y year increments and every
20 years is is uh is something different
right it's a that you know you know that
saying where it says strong people
create good times good times create weak
people weak people create bad times bad
times create uh you know good people
right or brave brave uh Stronger never
heard it uh well it's the same thing
right like you have these I'm going to
get into it I'm not going to [__]
butcher it do the [__] van nead check
out the channel you'll know what it is
by by the
title um so we're we're in a place in
which a lot of money came in you know
there's a lot of a lot of people that
benefited from it you know me included
but with that amount of money comes
certain amount of influence from outside
world that that that doesn't necessarily
live Esports the way that people live
Esports you guys see it in the weed
industry you guys call them chat ads
right where people who just want to make
a quick Buck come in [__] just throw
money at the wall and see what happens
well same thing happened in East not all
not across all of it but there were
certain instances in which dumb money
was thrown after dumb money like no
research done on on East sports teams on
which and what and they just thought
because you can create an uh anyway long
story short that's happening right now
we're we're seeing the tail end of of
that period right now where you know
money came in in time where Esports
didn't need it right and teams started
to get investment so that they could pay
more to the players which is a good
thing you know pay the players that this
is built on the players but at the same
time it wasn't time for those players to
get that race it wasn't time for that so
what you're seeing now is what happened
to what happened to rain right like they
got they got [__] duped by some
[__] [__] uh I met him once uh and I
met him a couple times but you know he
was trying to get optic to be the same
thing the FaZe was being in uh in this
[__] hubrick cubric if there's a
company out there that's named this and
it sounds like that I apologize but
there was something like that it was
this this idea where people anyway so
[__] they tried to get me to join
that dude tried to get me to join into
that that thing and I said no just
something fishy about him um and at the
time me Tommy and me banks uh we weren't
like uh not not not on speaking terms so
we were just we just weren't talking as
much as we did when we were both coming
up so I I didn't feel like I'm like if I
tell him I was like yo watch out for
this dude like I don't [__] know
right I'll be talking [__] so anyway
long story short like they they got
[__] a little bit man and and it's an
unfortunate thing I feel for them and
Esports is suffering across all of it
unless you have a brand like mine a
brand like face if face wouldn't have
taken you know those those uh if they
wouldn't get [__] they would have been
fine they would have been able to
operate on their own because they didn't
spend more than what they were making
ever and every person in that team was
making their own money and at the at the
same time pulling money into something
to help other creators come up right a
really good strategy organic strategy
made by us for us and and all that but
when you see eyeballs at the size that
that we're seeing the size that you guys
see like corporate people are just going
to want to sponsor that and why wouldn't
they and it's good but it is when the
external stuff that comes in and some is
good some helps is is when that money
comes in a lot of a lot of people that
aren't from here that aren't on the
front lines have an opinion now you know
they pay their way into having an
opinion for whatever reason right
they're looking for an Roi in popularity
or maybe they're looking an Roi in in in
in money right both work for them right
it's uh they have money they're buying
something so although there there have
been really good Investments uh there's
the ones that just don't pan out and
unfortunately happened to the biggest
brand in Esports which was Face Clan so
sad to see what's happening yeah well
you explained the [__] out of that yeah
that was amazing great exp thank you cuz
now I get it yeah it's the outsides like
you're saying you every day 8020 outside
influence comes in just like you're
saying the Chads not all of them but you
know some of it's 90% of this outside
influence in the weed industry has
watered it down and then I went to an
event about two months ago I told you it
felt like 2015 again it felt like I
walked around like I'm about to have fun
at an event are you [__] me oh bro
it was amazing and then what happened
they had another one same thing then I
saw like the Instagram Instagram is
where the Wii Community lived I know I
don't know if you knew that but that's
where it really started ironically yeah
that's where it really started yeah and
Instagram is shunned weed which is okay
but that that Community is still there
like it's still around it's still going
strong the outside influence of Chads I
don't hear as much anymore I don't hear
I don't hear as many people getting
[__] over and all those big guys yeah
exactly what happened the community went
nah we're not going to accept you what
happened Med mid went we'll just jump
the [__] off a cliff then big companies
like that just are tanking yeah because
they don't they they came in like no no
we're going to dictate the culture but
you can't do that you can't you got to
let it run wild man period you know it's
uh for me it was it's either tequila or
this or a hot sauce or
this there's million [__] hot sauces
out there really good ones Tequilas I
don't drink tequila I smoke weed so yeah
but uh yeah same to tell so to answer
your question about what you would tell
somebody is the same thing you can still
be a Creator and be successful you can
still be an orts player and be
successful Esports isn't not working
because of let me rephrase this Esports
is working the way it should be working
it might not be working financially for
those who have financial interest that
didn't pan out according to their
estimations because they're trying to
turn a 10-year-old into a 17-year-old
like that you got to let that thing
develop you got to let it have its legs
you got to let it get gain its own
strength to be what it is and it's
inevitable that it becomes uh a football
or a soccer the viewership is already
there and we're we've only been alive
for 20 years tops how old are how how
old is are the Cowboys right how old are
they like 50 years 75 years right like
give Esports team 50 years before you
call that [__] a failure because just
because millions of dollars came into
this thing billions of dollars came into
this thing and the money isn't returned
to you in a short amount of time doesn't
mean that Esports isn't working yeah
what that means is that the financial
model behind it isn't working
period MH so Esports is still good you
should still be passionate about it you
should still want to be in it if that's
why you want to be involved there's
nothing wrong with Esports there's
something wrong with the IND the
business industry of Esports it's always
like AOL it's like the music industry
it's always changing and evolving it's
good now things change and it's
different when did this you said dark
time when did that start uh 2015 oh
really yeah people people people saw the
popularity and then people saw teams
that were very popular and they they're
like all right the only way to get
popular like them so that we can get the
same amount of sponsorship as them so
that we can pay players you know
whatever is by getting an investment and
over paying for a player let's [__]
pay our not pay our way in because
they've been around for a while but
that's what happened people took
shortcuts man we didn't expand until we
had the money to expand that's why optic
was [__] what it that's why optic is
the OG right uh because we like Face
Clan and like I mean I think Face Clan
optic are the only teams in Esports that
have had that that that same the same um
strategy in glowing up the way that we
did where it was a self- sustainable
business because of the efforts of the
people around there were doing it the
people around it were creating content
because they were creatives right you
can say 100 thieves is like right there
but you know they don't have the same n
obviously my literal brother he's uh his
brain works [__] gorgeously when it
comes to this [__] um but OG OG is like
you know Face Clan and and optic like
it's it's uh it's what it what what it
was so when when you're not those teams
that have viewership because you're not
you're concentrating on on on winning
championships instead of of building an
audience a relationship with the people
uh you know it it's it it it does more
harm than than good right because if if
a tree falls in the middle of the forest
and nobody's surround to hear you win a
championship did you win a championship
[__] oh wisdom puff wisdom
puff I say that [__] all the
time practi so the reason why I asked
that dark times is because since the
last time youve been on the show you
invited us to the Call of Duty
Championship yeah
83% what of the people that were there
were there for optic oh it was green
yeah so you told me he you walk in do
this thing do this and I told Marty you
you so you never been to one before this
I no what I didn't know they existed
it's like watching The Mighty Ducks like
wait there's a whole world of fans and
people like wow it's just like the UFC
like just like the U I walked in but I
didn't expect it man I truly am if this
is the dark time then you guys are again
again there's nothing wrong with Esports
it's the business idea it when I walked
in I felt like I have been not knowing
about this culture this whole time there
was people lined up 50 deep and at the
end of like what are they waiting to
line for there was just aut there was
some like smaller dude with glasses he
sitting there taking pictures
yeah signning Xbox controllers what
color was he wearing green green yeah
who was it smaller white dude huh maybe
Dan was he an optic he was was I don't
know he's wearing there was oh maybe
Boston it could have been it doesn't who
there was a bunch of those how many
people recognize you there though um I
don't know a couple I bet you that if
you would have told people that you were
there you would have gotten mobbed oh oh
no no I went live for a second and but
and fools started walking upside exactly
yeah no no I was good I even to the side
just to try just to try to like oh no do
you know why because it's not it's not
even a separation of Industries it's
it's it's
YouTube yeah it's just like it covers
everything it's the best everyone smokes
weed everyone [__] smokes weed
everybody smokes weed except for my wife
no it's painful she doesn't either your
wife don't smoke at all no she'll never
what never did uh she tried it once oh
no she just got scared that's all yeah
that's what I tell her was she annoyed
by weed and kind of like hates it
overall she's getting over it you know
what I'm
saying no I I I you know well one I
don't [__] ever smoke in Texas right
so like we're we're free there but when
we are living in Los Angeles where it's
legal I make an effort to you know over
no to be away from them when it's Oh I
thought I make go [__] hard when we
no that means he's a ninja with it she
knows I mean she knows I mean she knows
right uh I just try to I just try to be
considerate not not a lot allow uh Marty
has a bong on the side of the house and
he sneaks like Spider-Man he drops in
low on upside down and he Coes back up
into his air vent and crawls back into
the ground your wife doesn't like the
smell of it she's got kids yeah she just
she's annoyed by weed overall yeah she
just needs to smoke a little bit of it
stays has she has she ever tried it yeah
yeah she's one of these people that used
to smoke weed when she was a kid then
she got [__] put on probation she had
to stop smoking weed for a long time now
it freaks her out yeah you know I've
tried believe me I she'll just be
talking I'll
just like she walks in I've seen him do
it it's [__] hilarious you're the a
[__] that type of [__] I try all the
time she's just annoyed by it it's not
working yeah so um Edibles
yeah oh oh God no I gave her a fraction
of a chibu one time and she went into
this this [__]
she thought literally her friend was in
town I ate most the [__] chibu like I
bar I gave them I like chomped it then I
took this piece ripped it in half and
gave it to them not even thinking twice
about it she went and do a goddamn
psychosis in her own mind thinking I'm
trying we were trying to kill her and go
off and be together she went
on I'm sleeping I ate the [__] and went
to sleep she stayed up all night she's
in the shower like all [__] freaking
out she didn't wake you up eventually
she did and I started [__] laughing I
I just tried to light the joint I saw I
saw I started laughing at her and [__]
told her it was normal normal to think
that she she had no clue that was a
normal weed thing you know what you know
what druck did that to me prazone what's
that steroid I had uh it was all right
so I I got a poison
ivy I thought it was the detergent at
first whatever anyway it was it get that
way I had po an ivy on my shins on both
both sides had them on my armpits I had
them on the on the on the watchi
triangle that wimen do not on my dick
not on my balls but on the on the sides
fuing and then guess at the top of
Satan's alley
too top of Satan's alley dude what were
you doing to get it in those positions I
think I think that it was and it's on
video I think it's when we went to we
went under a fence through bushes to go
paint a wall and and and we it's like a
skate park it's like it's legal it's not
like a legal thing but you you go under
it and I think that's where I got it or
it was on my backpack or something but I
I started right it started on this one
as soon as I got in the in the car I
started itching I'm like ah and then
later I'm like itching here and I'm like
oh man and then it was like it was
symmetrical it was symetrical so they
gave me the steroid called prazone and I
don't know where the [__] this [__]
conversation started but I'm going to
finish drugs edibl okay so yes prazone
prazone they gave me the
steroid it for the first time ever I
understood what being depressed was what
having dark thoughts were you know what
I'm saying and I'm like I'm like what
the [__] and i' I've never I've never
like thought negatively over anything
like my brain is incapable of like
overly thinking about something in a
negative
way but [__] that drug I'm never taking
it if it says even if it says own at the
end I'm not taking it did it happen
right away or did no gradual bro I was
my dreams were [__] uh how long were
we taking it huh just the one night no
no I took it uh it was 50 Mig a day and
there were the big tablets they're like
yo these are [__] heavy doses so
don't take more than one every 24 hours
right but it helped me like Get over the
the itch I I I would not wish that's how
I would torture someone Poison Ivy at
the top of Satan's alley bro and then I
cut their nails off so they wouldn't be
able to scrp you butt [__] naked when
you crawled under this fence how did you
get so much poison I did you have jeans
on I have jeans on
how I don't you think they call Devil's
alley no your Satan's s you're crack
your butt crack yeah yeah oh I I don't
know how I got back there walking in
it's under your arm but you can't put
your arms down bro and I and I I am you
know those people that are driving down
the highway and then see a car crash and
then they slow down to see what happened
I am opposite I'm like I see that and I
look the other way and I keep driving as
fast I canally [__] strong so I
didn't itch I did not I didn't scratch
that itch every so often I would sneak
one in to the back you know what I'm
saying but it wasn't it wasn't like
inside of it it was just like at the
entrance mhm you know right so you're
about to walk into into that alley
searching for the eye of
Mordor Lord of the Rings not a huge fan
no no no no sorry something think about
other movies if you like Game of Thrones
back still so how long this go on
for uh two weeks what the [__] give me
Co instead and I had Co and it was the
worst thing ever give me that instead
bro give me break an arm don't give me
[__] poison ivy two weeks of poison
ivy though it dud oh my god I've got
poison ivy before but two weeks medicine
make it way worse cuz you were all
[__] up maybe the stress of me being
negative maybe anyway long story short
I'm back to being pretty you know what
I'm saying I have I'm not deformed
anymore with [__] rashes everywhere
and [__] positive this [__] giv
gives me an edible and I don't I since I
since I had the shrooming accident
shrooming accident you guys I told it
last time didn't I told it yeah last
time I was here I don't think I saw
myself punch a guy you guys remember
that like in third person anyway it
doesn't matter December 31st 1999 that's
when I sh last and because I was
traumatized New Year Eve before the yeah
before Y2K G in eighth to the Dome first
time Shuman plus blunts plus drinks you
were going out you thinking that you
were going to die probably oh okay
that's what I thought you were doing for
no no no I no I I I saw my myself punch
a guy and I actually punched a guy in
reality but I saw myself in third person
anyway long story short I I'm like I
can't be out of control like that it's a
mature 19-year-old hex said that's too
powerful for you don't don't take that
[__] so I've never ingested any any
drugs right because I in that so he
gives me an uh he didn't give me the Ed
uh my boy ens gave me an edible I ate uh
a little bit of it and then I'm I'm I
ate it it was uh it was right after I
had gotten over um the the the
rash and boy I got to tell you something
that edible [__] hit me and I was
watching like everything just got Qui
got quiet in my head I was watching the
[__] basketball the finals with my
wife my wife was sitting next to me she
didn't know I took oh no that's the
worst right and all I'm watching
everything sco
[Music]
all
anyway I'm like I have this I have this
thing where I get too high I look at the
time 204 because you know how when
you're high you're like oh my god I've
been high for [__] 20 minutes it's
never going to end 205 205 it's been a
minute relax it helps it helps it helps
so I'm watching the [__] thing and
I'm like all right 5:45 left in that
game 5:45 boom boom boom boom boom watch
and watching watch and it's like and I
look back and it's like 5:45 still they
were a timeout right but I didn't
realize they were
[__] I'm starting to freak out right
and I'm like I'm like oh my God I'm so
[__] she's right next to me and all I
wanted to say
is hold
me please put your arms around me
woman she doesn't know this right said
she won't she won't watch this she
doesn't watch she watched some of the
stuff that I do but not everything so
hopefully she's not watching baby I'm
sorry I didn't tell you that but anyway
I'm sitting there and I'm watching this
[__] I'm just like I'm [__] I'm like
oh man I'm like I'm just waiting for the
game to be over so I can say all right
I'm going to bed
right cuz we're sitting there I'm just
sitting there counting the [__] days
she knew you were that high would she be
like are you [__] serious would it be
like that no no no no no and I don't
know why I was afraid to tell her that I
I I felt like I was about to I felt like
I felt when I got Fs in high school in
oh failure no I didn't feel like a
failure when I was [__] failing
classes you know but but other people
felt like I was Dumb and [__] like I
knew I wasn't dumb you know what I'm
saying you know when you're when you're
clever and you know when you when you
have intelligence in you
a [__] F on a piece of paper for me
not knowing a [__] equation or
swimming or swimming [__] that
that doesn't describe my intelligence so
I didn't feel bad but I my dad was a
very strict man beat the [__] out of me
so you know I was scared right and
that's how I felt I don't know why but I
was like maybe just the edible making me
transporting me back to when I was like
8 years old and [__] and I'm saying that
and I just wanted to be like hold me and
[__] you know like I'm I'm feeling like
[__] and I look and it's like 4 minutes
and I'm like this is the longest [__]
game ever and then finally finally as
it's winding down my legs go numb and
I'm like I'm like oh my God and I'm
wiggling my [__] toes and I'm like oh
my God I'm [__] like [__] uh uh
flexing my calf muscles and I'm like I
don't [__] I'm not even cramping I
don't F feel [__] [__] and she's
sitting right next to me and I'm just
[__] watching it's all happening in
my [__] head my world is falling
apart and no one knows it I'm just
[__] staring at this [__] game and
trying to interact I'm like a [__] you
should have made that [__] now I'm
paralyzed I'm paralyzed you know I'm
like [__] man and I'm like oh my God
what if I also lose control over my anus
and [__] myself [__] myself I'm like oh
please don't fart please don't fart I'm
all of these negative thoughts are
coming in my head and I'm just like
Jesus Christ and then bam [__]
whistle blows and I'm like all right I'm
going to bed and I'm like oh my god did
I say that weird did I say that weird so
I'm walking into my my room did I say
that weird I'm like all right just get
in there and just [__] laid down and
I died
oh man you never hear a story end like
that and I
died and I died exactly why I think that
was
ridiculous I thought you were going to
say and then I did [__] and then I died
no no no I relate to that type of [__]
so much you're trying to play it off Mar
will eat shrooms and be like my kids
walked in and I was just typing it's
like they were so tall it's like they
have to be here in my [__] heart
right now like you'll be sitting there
in a movie next to your wife like I
can't you can't
fold anyway I've taken I've taken edible
sends so like I'm I'm I'm like a little
bit more used to it but it's always like
tiny tiny little pieces of it I don't I
don't think that my I'm just not that's
not my thing you know what I'm saying
like I got a a funny like uh somebody
who took too much story here on the news
from my local sports team the Buffalo
Bills I'd like to get your reaction to
from this headline
they're building a new stadium next to
the bills current stadium and it's
[__] stupid because it's a smaller B
it's [__] 20 minutes outside of
downtown hisory C it's got no history D
it's got no [__] roof they're
building with no [__] roof so anyway
there's a construction site next to the
bill Stadium yeah the headline Bills fan
high on LSD cocane and marijuana's
rescued from a 40ft hole outside the
stadium after stripping naked covering
himself in human feces from a portapotty
and then jumping a fence into the
construction c yeah
tweaker I guess yeah I saw I saw those
news I saw it fu is it [__] up that I
just saw it I'm like yes because it
should be like oh my God so sad I'm
desensitized bro I just feel covering
himself in the [__] is what really does
it for me and then you get trapped in a
[__] hole drug and do [__] I have no
remorse like you knew what you were
getting into no it was a muddy place
though it was like it really muddy it
but it wasn't [__] then no it's both no
he went into a porta pooty and covered
himself in [__] I don't know what you
know he didn't plan to fall into this
hole it's
a how else was he going to camouflage in
the for what for whatever reason that a
good [__] point let just say this the
bills are going to do good this season
that's not a curse they took all the
shitty [__] out of the season for dud
this is Bill's activity right some
Chicago and needs to [__] some
Chicago needs to [__] piss themselves
cover themselves in [__] or something
cuz we need help got to step it up rest
of the league right yeah D I'm a Packers
fan so like it's over for us I wasn't a
Packers fan but I was a Brett Favre fan
oh I was a br yeah during yeah me too
like since 1997 the quarterback
challenge he's he threw 75 yards on his
back foot and it was windy as [__] to
win
it does like he always does yeah cuz
Annie was drunk Annie was drunk in our
perks about that [__] perk said br
[__] through beams let's say this
Brett Favre was my hero then he openly
dissed me at the game as a child dissed
me looked at just dissed the [__] out of
me have a he broke my heart yeah still
loved he didn't even see you I bet you
he didn't see the only fan he it was
perus at Brett far he was 3 feet from us
he ignored all of us it was crazy anyway
[__] him yeah and then I still love him
yeah and then you hear what happened I
don't know how he's not in prison yet
this man stole from from the the
orphanage oh yeah the store from the
welfare department bre har is going out
bad million di that cancellation like no
other he that [__] like a [__] Blitz
and then threw it off his back foot 75 y
he said 75 yards he's the man he's the
strongest arm ever but I was just
talking about this yesterday cuz
somebody was from Wisconsin I used to I
did a report on Wisconsin because they
used to pick your state in fourth grade
all I did was talk about the Packers and
Brett F got a [__]
F that's it that's the whole story say
guys that's what I want to talk about
and the teacher was a [__] [__] you
know what she did she just circled the F
and
Favre and then a big arrow pointing at
it so that you get there as a kid and
you look at it like oh what this arrow
and then you look F you're like [__]
that's cool me if I ever become a
teacher I'm going to do stupid [__] to
kids yeah kind of I'll never become a
teacher but damn that'd be tight as hell
Could you teach a joint rolling class
like in front of an audience I love I
love rolling joints
[__] yeah yeah I work with my hands I
love I'm I'm an artisan of sorts so of
course I have to roll a great blunt and
a good joint oh you roll a great blunt
and a and a joint and a good joint well
great joint sorry yeah got completely
off track what were we talking about so
when I went into the Call of Duty Call
of Duty World Championship yeah you guys
it's like a soccer game in there they
were chanting when you guys were out on
the thing green wall man what the [__]
people had jerseys they were lineing up
buying jerseys it's
like it's like dodgeball when
like was it Sports Center hey oo or
whatever like yo there's a whole world
of people that like [__] and I went in
they like no this is like a [__]
soccer game people were chanting they
were chanting no I haven't no is is
there stars like how in UFC there's like
a top five and then there's like kind of
the you know but those top five are
[__] superstars
yeah big promo deals and Sh jerseys
people had
jerseys selling jerseys you got to be a
badass to have your own Jersey and
that's why people like that [__] cuz
you're a
badass they had the gamer jerseys but
they also had the soccer jersey probably
somebody there was wearing the uh the
hockey jersey it was the hockey jersey
the hockey jerse was sick right they
hockey jersey optic oh [__] I need one
of them things I we have none but Xbox
controllers too correct oh yeah there
was that was part that was part of my
gift I was gonna bring I know you guys
don't play but I was I was goingon to
bring you guys controllers oh put that
[__] up in the office yeah no I I'm I'm
literally flew here from uh collector I
got home and then flew here from Chicago
didn't have a chance to go to the
storage oh you were filming and eating
yesterday no no no no so from Chicago
went home packed and then left to Laguna
Beach uh Sunday and then yesterday I
came to LA and then got got got so
didn't get a chance to go to my store at
home to pack the [__] to go there oh
yeah good man yeah but I am going to
ship it but I just wanted to say going
there changed my perspective on Esports
yeah it is shocking yeah because I even
said like there's nobody like I walked
up like there's nobody outside there no
taing and [__] what kind of sported this
and walked in like oh they're
respectable people they're not drunk
[__] screaming for the bills and the
[__] Bears and Packers and [__] you
got your boo out there but not there was
people drinking but also like yo I'm
here to game my ass off I want people
were watching the [__] fools are on
stage Marty yeah playing Call of D I was
talking about this this one very
specific dude named Boozer that's
why he shoes and [__] [__] oh yeah
super super
partyer dude can you imagine being the
[__] man at Call of Duty you have
your own Jersey like yo let's get [__]
up because why I don't got to train
tonight and [__] run six miles and
still be a superstar yo that [__] is
cool man oh gamer gamer they're [__]
fit in is super serious too I'm just
saying it's like Beerfest [__] yeah
we're we're all athletes you know what
I'm saying you are Esports man you what
I'm saying esport it just blew it just
blew my I called him I filmed it that
just it was awesome is VR a part of
Esports at all not yet inevitable though
uh was AR well my kid plays the VR
literally afterwards his arms are sore
like as if you been push-ups sh just
tight it gets me dizzy that's the only
thing I get I'm like if
if it's not calibrated to you if you
wear prescription it's going to be a
different experience um it got me sick I
felt nauseous like it can't be 60 frames
it has to be 24 frames if I remember
correctly I may be talking out my ass
but at some point it had to be a certain
frames per second otherwise you you
would get dizzy because your eyes have a
way of discerning that although look I
don't know [__] you're cra real
technical right there I'm good I was
just like I'm like I'm not I'm not going
to be able to follow
through 6 halfway through that [__] no
it's all good man um so Pine Park you
guys are [__] doing your thing in
other states now also Y which is super
sick optic you're still crushing doing
your thing and you said now you're in
business meeting is doing your business
part of that but like I said that I
think that comes with everything and now
that you're saying you're smoking a
joint during the zoom that's amazing
it's one thing we we did a meeting one
time and I think maybe we shouldn't have
done a certain thing but the guy was
smoking a joint as we were talking was
like this there can't be bad yeah
smoking weed while you're talking to me
like hey man everybody smokes weed even
people bad at business apparently yeah
dude the best thing that I see all the
time is like older people not giving a
like not not that they don't give a [__]
but smoking publicly like when when
second we landed in Chicago we went to
this place called um the something for
some beefs and uh I saw this this this
tall gray-haired white dude [__] slim
dude but you can tell that he was like
5670 no I'm kidding 5660 right like an
older gentleman [__] smoking a blunt
not not just a [__] joint a [__]
blunt just walking by just puffing on
that [__] walking and I'm like I'm like
man how good it must feel for him to
have had to wait this long for him to
enjoy life the way that he would have
always enjoyed life you know what I'm
saying so it's uh that's the coolest
thing I've seen about about that part oh
yeah it's like a human rights thing like
[__] I can just be me out here without
you [__] yeah kidnap me taking me to
jail over this [__] yeah that's some New
York [__] makes no sense like Chicago's
completely CH if this show the way that
it's filmed right now was happening in
uh Texas or in other like think about
that what has happened in here besides
conversation amongst friends smoking a
little bit of weed this which is we
could have been drinking a beer getting
shots and getting [__] up on [__]
gold schnapper or something M [__]
gold you know what I'm saying flakes you
see them like corn it's only borrowed um
so it says
as anyway so yeah long story short it's
like it's it's asinine to me that people
in a room like this not bothering
[__] anyone yeah all the laughs all
the motivational things that come out of
this show like we'd have been getting
our [__] door booted in yeah g scary
yeah I think about that often I'm very
lucky you guys grew up outside of where
I grew up yeah I have never worried ever
and that's something that I think I take
for granted cuz when I go to other
places I'm like this is what it's like
to have anxiety oh [__] there's a cop I
have two zips on me oh [__] that shit's
scary yeah I don't do that [__] yeah no
it's not worth it when you have all the
business [__] going I yeah don't do it m
yeah I
don't pire get into like the alternative
stuff at all yeah look uh like music
nirada and [__] no I'm kidding so we we
uh we we talk a lot about like what else
we could do that'd be cool for the brand
and uh pine bark is one of those
things I mean List like at that you
immediately know what it is because you
know that pets also need CBD also need
the benefits from this thing so getting
creative pine bark I thought was a good
one my wife I mean we have eight dogs or
do you seven seven what kind of dogs do
you have I have uh I I'm going to say I
I still have a my boy scoffield passed
away 16 years old this year
January uh so three three Chihuahua a
Pomeranian a bishan freeze a mini golden
doodle a gold wait let me count it again
so three three Chihuahua a Pomeranian a
bishan freeze a mini golden doodle a
golden doodle and a great D Mastiff
named Henry do she have one monster yeah
bro and he protects all the other six
little sh this big Jesus Christ that
thick that thick that's a lot [__]
[__] man it's easy to pick up though
it's like picking up a bat but just the
handle just pick it up your hand just
[__] throw it out I don't do it I'm
too pretty to pick that [__] up I told
my my girl you getting these
dogs Pi [__] up a listen I don't care
who picks up it ain't going to be me
though I I'll puke you going have to
still pick up the [__] but it's got
might puke on it I did that as a kid
that was my job have to pick it up D
it's like I I stopped changing do
diapers when my daughter started eating
human food I would I couldn't handle it
if I saw you like do a lugie where you
suck it back up I will puke right
[__] now no stop I'm yeah D don't do
when you do that I'm going to join you I
will join you every time I watch Big
Daddy and they do it I have I have to
leave the room I leave the room oh I
don't I'm I'm not gonna tell you what
happened but you have a bunch of dogs
you have a bunch of dogs and they all
sit on the big dog all of them can fit
on his back yeah easily no not not what
a wild who decided to go hey let's get a
big
one he was he had the same birthday as
me so you picked him up yeah he likes
blue too my wife uh she was at the store
and she's like she's like oh my god do
you remember when you were a kid and you
you told me you used to hang from a
great thing's neck and I remember that
that would like hang from when I was
like a kid and I was like yeah he's like
well there's a great thing here with
your same birthday and I was like I'm
like do not get another [__] dog do
not get another [__] dog Jude Jude
please don't get another [__] dog and
then she calls me she like oh my God I'm
made a connection with him and I'm like
I'm like God damn it fine get him and
then the second that I saw him I was
like oh my God a puppy bigger than all
your dogs yeah bro and and it was
awesome cuz he was already bigger than
everybody else at the time as a baby so
he was out there learning how to [__]
walk and [__] you know like a deer yeah
exactly dude my sister had a great day
and things are he's taller than me when
he stands yeah that shit's it's insane
yeah put their they just I waited yeah
so I waited until he was mature to
neuter him uh wanted his two full years
of of testosterone and and Adolescence
in theory to for him to be as big as he
could uh and then when we chopped his
balls off oh avocado bro like big big
beautiful balls this [__] dog had I
kept them yeah no I didn't it's not a
bad idea gross bro why why I it gross
it's so sad like and then you don't
collect stuff I chopped his balls off
yeah somebody has Napoleon's penis
somewhere [__] Jer out fermenting
somewhere anyway so at the same time
that we that we got him neutered we
stapled his stomach because Great Dan as
you know like have a short life
expectancy uh most of the time is
because their stomachs flip and you
can't undo them because just picture a
balloon in there are you serious and
it's like you can't you can't digest it
right so they and and because they have
big hearts and because of the way that
everything moves internally like
something's happen stom flip yeah no I'm
I'm repeating what I heard my wife
saying third hand no I'm just like I I I
have ADHD and she you know she has to
repeat times some she gets a no with me
why wouldn't she be but yeah anyway so
from what I remember her saying I think
that's what happened so when we neutered
them they also stapled the stomach to
give him a better chance of being you
know to living
longer Cosmetics so pine bark man hey
when you chop his balls off cut his
stomach in half Oh my he must have woke
up pissed yeah give me some
weed it's like it's like July 4th pine
bark July 4th the Sparks are going to
get your dog
scared in the dark try some Pine bark
make the [__] go to sleep for a
little oh that's not a bad oh you know
that's crazy yeah it's exactly what
Rosy's mom and dad does on Fourth of
July they give him the CBD ones oh
really yeah dude the other thing one of
the first ideas that we had was like uh
like CBD ointment for for gamers
Knuckles obviously you you need the
recovery like people don't understand
the the the the the medicinal actual
recovery that this thing does right uh I
remember back in in in harez uh um I
remember I don't know what family member
it was but it was one of my aunts or
could have been my mom I don't know who
it was but I saw weed inside of alcohol
bottle for for rubbing and the medicinal
purposes um so yeah you know it's
another option so my grandma had it yeah
people that are against weed and
drinking they had it in the bottle it's
just leaves and nug yeah in a bottle of
rubbing
alcohol and it can take you places jug
it I did tincture for the first time
yesterday you like it it's [__]
awesome what what made you say you saw
it you're like yeah I was like why I
[__] around with these [__] Edibles
let me just get the [__] tinure you
you chug it no I just took one dropper
okay I was one dropper is like one
bottle had 1,000 milligram yeah you
dropped oh my God I got a shitload of
tinctures in my house in my fridge if
you want some a lot yeah apparently I
like them all right his tolerance is
[__] shock it's like a in video like
uh there's a diffusion filter you can
put on your camera where it makes
everything very glowy and soft
it was like yeah I was at the [__]
with sports lights and [__] at the field
looking at them
like that dad's High that's what that's
what happened to me during that
Spiritual Awakening during the finals
you know I was just everything was
glowing yeah I need that I want to see
[__]
different um okay so guys we've been
here for a minute and I know you got to
get out of here um where can everybody
find and support everything optic gaming
work can they bu here where can they get
everything well look uh F I mean follow
optic at optic gaming on Twitter or I'm
sorry optic on Twitter 3 million plus
followers 3.1 we dropped down since
since the sale but you know we're
working our way back up
there uh and then uh Pine park at Pine
Park also on Twitter and uh Pine Park HQ
on uh yeah well Twitter Youtube and all
the platforms easy to find cool so and
what day does the show drop uh uh
usually on Thursdays right Friday well
we record on Thursdays and then Fridays
yeah okay so Fridays they you watch the
podcast watch the Munch that's uh the
cheat code right food and the
relatability of it like the Munch that
these guys produce is [__] phenomenal
phenomenal food show awesome
yeah and idiots right yeah watch idiots
if you like graffiti if you like art can
they watch that on YouTube on my channel
yeah hex heex okay on YouTube flash and
Instagram same everything right yeah
yeah yeah all right good [__] I wish I
lived down here so we could do this more
often it's kind of wild that you're like
yo I'll come out there and get high as
[__] my my brain would be like no I'm
going to just live out here smoke a
bunch of weed and then you can see the
house size you're like I think I'm live
in Texas yeah yeah I've been seeing it a
fact I've been see 10 dogs more fit in
the house and I it's kind of shocking
how much room you guys got out there
yeah I went out there for the first time
last year yeah he's a lot of land where
where uh I went to Dallas and Houston
dude next time you're in Dallas you [__]
can tell me I'm going to take oh you
guys don't need food yeah I know see see
some avocados I'll eat the [__] out of
avocado right
now my favorite restaurant all right
well thank you Marty anything else thank
you sir we appreciate you coming through
this was thanks for the invite man long
long overdue it's been a I didn't know
it a year yeah [__] year since you've
been here lots changed you guys in
different different states making shows
doing your thing appreciate you for
being here you smoked all your joints
yeah I had a little help in the end but
nobody ever smokes no to the filter too
like not some took three Puffs off it
like John and put it down yeah right
exactly I had my homie on last week and
you no no he smoked and we dabbed and
[__] but yeah no I'm saying but for the
taste and after that he just doesn't
like it I think he's just talking yeah
he's just talking yeah I I do that
sometimes you know when I'm in LA and
I'm by myself I start smoking when I'm
like ah I'm cool I like I like where I'm
at right now and I'll go back to it I've
always got to that point I'm like I'm
high and I'm like well I still joint
yeah no and that's why I can't focus on
drawing here we go all right guys thank
you so much Marty thank you for being
here hex thank you for being here guys
from everybody here the dope as usual
podcast thank you for watching be safe
driving have a dope ass day hey nice
that was a smooth outro it was I didn't
I didn't stutter or anything so good
good sh thanks for the invite thank you
for being
[Music]
here
perfect
[Music]